[Music]
oh
peace TV the solution for Humanity
[Music]
la
[Applause]
asalam
alayum brothers and sisters it is indeed
a
fantastic
opportunity to see such a lovely
gathering at this mega event peace for
Humanity when this whole concept was
conceived it was only a
dream which has now been realized thanks
to Allah subhana taala the response is
phenomenal imagine
such a big Muslim festival for 10 days
how often do we get an opportunity like
this to gather all Muslim and non-muslim
brothers and sisters Under One
Roof indeed we are fortunate and we
should be thankful to Allah for giving
us such an
opportunity in today's world scenario we
feel that there is a need for promoting
better ideals amongst the
youth with whether one is a follower of
Islam or any other
religion it is essential to know the
ultimate power on Earth as I belong to
the religion of Islam I thought this is
my duty to bring the Youth of today to
know not only the ideals of the religion
but also the need to live with communial
Harmony for the good of the world as a
whole in order to know about the
religion for communal Harmony
one is to be educated to the utmost this
event is purely for communal Harmony is
for awareness and it is for
education I request brother Ashraf to
give the bataa of brother Zakir nyak
before he starts his lecture
shukran Dr Zakir nyak is a medical
doctor by professional training but he's
an internationally acclaimed orator on
Islam and comparative religion he
clarifies and clears misconceptions
about Islam using Quran authentic Hadith
and other religious scriptures which he
quotes verbatim in conjunction with
reason logic and scientific facts he's
popular for his critical analysis and
convincing answers to challenging
questions posed by audiences worldwide
after his public talks he has delivered
public talks in the USA Canada UK Saudi
Arabia UAE Australia South Africa
Botswana Malaysia Singapore Hong Kong
Thailand Guyana South America and many
other countries in addition to numerous
other talks in
India shik Ahmed datat the world famous
orator and Islam and comparative
religion has called Dr zakin nyak datat
plus Dr zakin nyak appears regularly on
many International TV channels in more
than 150 countries of the world more
than 100 of his talks dialogues debates
and symposia are available on debes he
has authored several books on Islam and
comparative religion I present before
you brothers and sisters Dr Zakir naak
who speak on the topic the purpose of
creation alhamdulillah
the respected people on the D my
respected elders and my dear brothers
and sisters I welcome all of you with
the Islamic greetings
may peace mercy and blessings of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala of almighty God be on
all of
you the topic of this evening's talk is
the purpose of
creation this question what is the
purpose of
creation arises in the mind of every
individual sometime or the other
irrespective whether he's rich or poor
king or poer black or white yellow or
brown whether he lives in America or UK
whether he lives in India or Saudi
Arabia this question sometime or the
other crops up in the mind of each and
every
individual why have we been
created why are we here what is our
purpose in this
world and most of the human
beings they think that there has to be a
supreme
creator that is almighty God and because
of him we are
here however there is a
minority who do not believe in the
existence of the creator of almighty God
and they assume that the full
world has come into existence by chance
and we human beings too we have come
into being by
chance suppose you see on the beach the
footprints of a human being immediately
a logical person he thinks that these
Footprints have been
created by the walking of a
person a logical person will not assume
that the footprints came into existence
by chance or the footprints came into
existence by the waves coming on the
beach and when the waves went away it
created these Footprints a logical
person will realize that these
Footprints have been created by a person
it had a
purpose why it was
created this question what is the
purpose of
creation can be answered in two
perspectives number one one from the
perspective of the
creator that is almighty God and second
by the perspective of the creation that
is human being the first perspective is
the view of the Creator almighty God
what caused him to create the human
being what caused him to create this
creation and number two from the
perspective of the creation that the
human beings that why were we created by
almighty
God those people who do not agree in the
existence of almighty God and believe
that we have come in this world by mere
chance according to this philosophy
there is no difference between the human
beings and all the other creation all
have come by chance even the human
beings as well as the
animals so these people do not have a
particular purpose in life at all they
they don't have a purpose for
existence
and they live the same way as the
animals drink sleep rest and procreate
that's it so the purpose of the animals
and the human beings become the same to
eat to drink to rest to sleep and to
procreate and because they don't have a
purpose they try and strive excellence
in eating in drinking in
living and they become materialistic and
that's the reason for such people
materialism becomes a
God and because of this these same
people they create drugs just to own
money to have a Better
Living they create bombs and weapons of
mass
destruction they involve in fornication
in adultery in homosexuality in
pornography it doesn't make a difference
to them whether they make drugs or
whether they involve themselves in
pornography the main purpose is just
nothing but materialism let us discuss
today the
answer to this question what is the
purpose of creation from both point of
view first we'll discuss from the
Creator's point of view from the point
of view of almighty God from the point
of view of Allah subhana wa taala what
caused him to create the human
beings Allah subh says in the Quran in
Surah chapter number 40 verse number
57 that the creation of the heavens and
the Earth are far greater than the
creation of the human beings but most of
the human beings here they realize it
not many human beings feel that we are
the greatest of the
creation but Allah says that the
creation of the Heaven and the Earth is
far greater than the creation of the
human
beings and in reply to this query
that why Allah subhah wa ta'ala why
almighty God created us one of the
attributes of Allah subhana wa ta'ala of
almighty God is the creator the best
Creator and Allah says in the
Quran in suron chapter number 23 verse
number 14 that Allah subhana wa tala
almighty God is the best to create if
there is a Creator if his attribute is
Creator there has to be a creation
if there's no creation then there cannot
be a
creator for
example if you call a person as the best
writer but naturally will ask him that
where is the material you have written
where is the book you have written where
is the article you have written so when
he presents the article of the book then
we can say fine he is the best writer
similarly since one of the attributes of
Allah subhana wa taala is the creator
the best Creator he has to have a
creation
but that does not mean that Allah
subhana wa ta'ala is dependent on his
creation Allah say in the Quran in Surah
zum chapter number 39 verse number 62
that it is Allah subhana wa ta'ala who
creates
everything and he's independent of all
his
creation he's not dependent on these
things but the Creations are dependent
on Allah subhana wa tala the Arabic word
for creat khik to create the Arabic word
is
kalak kalaka can divided into two
types one meaning ofak is to
create something from something which
besides Allah subhana wa ta'ala even we
human beings and other creation can do
for example a
carpenter who creates a chair and a
table with the help of wood and nails
but the wood has been obtained from the
trees which has not been created by the
carpenter not by human beings but by
Allah subhana wa tala the nails have
been obtained from metal which have been
obtained from Rock which again is a
creation of Allah subhana wa ta'ala so
all the Creations done by human beings
they're dependent on basic elements all
of which have been created by Allah
subhana waala so this type of creation
to create something from something is is
a limited type of
creation the ultimate and the true
creation is to create something from
nothing and this no one besides Allah
subhana tala can do to create something
from nothing this is the ultimate
creation which none of the creation can
do except the uncreated Allah subhana wa
ta'ala who the creator of all the
creation since his
attribute is the creator they have to be
creation there are various attributes
given in the Quran for example he called
as arahman
Alim the merciful the kind the
forgiver the creation of the human
beings is a unique
creation we human beings we have a free
will of our own we can either obey our
creator almighty God or we can disobey
it is a unique
creation and because we have this
ability to either obey or disob our
creator we can even sin we can sin and
only because the human beings can sin
can the quality of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala as being the forgiver being kind
being
merciful can be known if human beings if
he did not have a free will and if we
had followed everything what Allah has
commanded there would be no difference
between us and the angels the angels are
a creation of Allah subhana wa ta'ala
who do not have a free will of Their Own
they obey each and every commandment of
Allah subhana wa tala because they don't
have a free will of their own but the
human beings have a free
will and because of this free
will the mercy of Allah subhana wa taala
the kindness of Allah subhana wa taala
the Forgiveness of Allah subhana tala
can be known the other attribute of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala that is given in
the Quran is loving and Allah subhana wa
ta'ala says in several places in the
Quran that he loves those people who
trust in him those people who are
patient those who are righteous those
who are Pious those who are patient and
perseverance those who approach him and
those who trust in him and Allah says in
the Quran in Surah al- Imran chapter
number three verse number 31 he tells to
the last and final messenger Prophet
Muhammad Sall Ali wasallam he tells him
that tell that if you love Allah follow
me and Allah will love you and forgive
you your sins the prophet has been
commanded by the creat Allah subhana wa
ta'ala to tell the people that if you
love Allah you have to follow me that is
follow the prophet and Allah subhana wa
tala will love you and he will forgive
your sins and there's a Hadith ofam
mentioned and has been authenticated as
by
and number
3540 where our beloved Prophet Mahi
wasallam he
says that that if you ask Allah Allah
says if you approach to me I will answer
you and if you ask for forgiveness I
will forgive you even if your sins reach
up to the cloud I will forgive you even
if your sins are as big as the complete
Earth I will approach you in the same
way with forgiveness as long as you ask
for forgiveness and do not associate
partners with me that means whatever sin
you do as as long as you ask for
forgiveness with sincere repentance if
you do not associate partners with Allah
subhana tala don't do shik Allah subhana
wa tala he will forgive you one of the
attributes of Allah subhana wa taala is
the grace and the Beloved Prophet mmall
wasam said it's mentioned in sah Muslim
volume number four Hadith number
6765 where the Prophet said that do the
right things do the best Deeds to the
best of your ability and be happy
do the right things to the best of
ability and be
happy for no one can enter Jenna only on
the basis of his deeds so one of the
sahabas asked that what about you Allah
so the prophet said not even
I I cannot enter Jenna
unless with the mercy of Allah subhana
wa tala and his grace unless his grace
and mercy and his forgiveness envelop me
I cannot enter Jenna so here we realize
that without the grace of Allah subhana
wa ta'ala no one can enter
jenah and Allah subhana tala says in the
Quran in Sur Anam chapter number 6 verse
number 160 Allah says that if you do any
good deeds I will multiply it 10 times
into your account and if you do any evil
deed I will only count it as once for
Allah he does not do anything wrong so
here we realize that if any good deed
you do Allah subh says in the Quran he
will multiply it minimum 10 times into
your
account if you do any evil deed he'll
count as one that means if everyone was
accounted one point for his good deed
and one point for the evil deed without
multiplication of the Good Deeds not a
single human being would have entered
Jenna it is the grace of Allah subhana
wa ta'ala that he multiplies your good
deeds and gives you multiple times more
reward that you shall go to
jenah that does not mean that Deeds
aren't important important Deeds are
very important but the grace is more
important without the grace of Allah you
cannot enter Jenna Allah multiplies but
your Deeds also should be there if your
deed is there don't even multiply if
your Deeds are zero and if you multiply
with even million times it will be
useless so Deeds also important but
without the grace of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala
no human being can enter
Paradise so because of his quality
attribute of being merciful kind
forgiving love loving and
Grace all these are manifested in the
creat Allah subhana wa ta'ala
and one of the attributes is also
supreme
justice and Allah subhana wa ta'ala he
has in me
gab before person is born he knows that
after person is born whether he'll do
good deeds or bad Deeds whether he
listen to The Commandments of Allah
subhana tala or will disobey he knows he
even knows whether the person will go to
Janam or Jenna whether they'll go to
hell or Paradise he
knows but if Allah subhana wa ta'ala
moment a person is born or before he's
born he puts him in heaven person who
deserves heaven and puts the person in
Hell who deserves hell the people who
have been put in heaven they may not
object they may say fine alhamdulillah
we have been put into heaven no problem
but surely those people who have been
put in hell they will object that how
come you haven't let us lead our life
and without a test you have put us in
hell so because Allah subhana wa ta'ala
is just Allah says in the Quran Ina
chapter number four verse number 14
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is never
unjust in the least degree that's the
reason Allah subhana wa ta'ala lets the
people live in this
world and if you follow the Commandments
of Allah subhana wa tala you pass the
test otherwise you fail the
test and people may ask that one of the
pillars of Iman the last pillar is is
Destiny and Allah says in the Quran in
Sur s chapter number 32 verse number
12 Allah says all these people who will
go to hell on the day of judgment they
will never object to the justice of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala they will say
all these Sinners they will bow their
head down and say please forgive us they
will agree with the Lord they will say
please give us one more chance
so that we can go again in the world and
that time we will surely be
Believers but Allah knows that even if
he forgives them and puts them back into
this world but natural he'll have to
wash out their memory of what they have
seen of the
hell Allah is sure that they'll again
commit the same mistake and this is
mentioned in the Quran in Sur Anam
chapter number 6 verse number
28 that if these people were again sent
in the word they would repeat the same
mistakes because they are liars so Allah
knows in his Divine wisdom that these
people even if he sends them again if
the memory is washed out of what they
seen of the hell they will do the same
mistakes but coming to the question ofar
is the sixth pillar of
Iman that Allah subhana wa ta'ala we
Muslims believe that Allah writes the he
wres the
destiny and people may object many
people ask this question Muslims and
non-muslims
alike that if everything Allah has
written in the destiny that find whether
this person is going to do good or bad
whether they're going to commit a murder
or whether they're going to commit a
rape or whether they're going to rob or
whether they going to do good deeds
whether they're going to go to Hell or
Heaven if everything is mentioned then
there is our choice who's to blame if I
commit a murder Allah wrote in the I'm
going to commit a murder and I commit a
murder who's to blame Allah is to blame
so why should I be in
hell and this is a very logical
question the reply to this question is
that we have to understand the concept
of and Destiny that Allah subhana wa
ta'ala has destined things where a
person going to be born in which
condition he'll be born when will he die
which land will he die Allah says in the
Quran in Surah is 17 verse number 14
that whenever a child is born the f is
bound on his neck the moment he's born
Allah knows everything what going do
good or bad right or wrong whether going
to go to Hell or Heaven but Allah
subhana wa ta'ala
has I let give you an example there
suppose in a class there the
teacher who teaches about 100 students
for about one year and before the
examination that teacher predicts that
this student he will come out first in
class first class first this student
he'll get second class that St will fail
just an example don't feel bad
brother
now after a few days the examination
takes place and this student comes out
first class first this student gets
second class and that student fails now
I'm asking you a question can the
student who failed can you object to the
teacher that because you predicted I'm
going to fail I have failed who's to
blame the teacher or the student who's
to blame the student the teacher
predicted this student he plays hookie
he doesn't class he sees movie therefore
he's going to fail that student is okay
average that student is very intelligent
does good hard work so teacher predicts
in advance before the examination this
student get a first class first this
student second class that student fail
and the student comes out first class
first second class that student fails
but because the teacher predicted that
does not mean the teacher is to blame
the teacher has taught everyone
correctly and
equally similarly Allah subhana
has he has knowledge of the future
certain things they destined he has said
that this person is born in this land on
this particular date he'll die in this
land in this particular date Etc his
surrounding he'll be wealthy or whatever
it is but the choice is yours for
example after you pass your 12th
standard you have a choice of BEC an
engineer or becoming a doctor or
becoming a lawyer the choice is yours
you choose to become an engineer
so Allah already knows in advance that
after you pass your standard 12th you
will choose to become an engineer he's
written in advance it is not because
Allah has written that you are
choosing it is because you have chosen
Allah has written in
advance the choice is yours but Allah
knows your choice for example if you
come at a crossroad and there are five
roads Road number one 2 3 4 5 the choice
is yours you can either take Road Number
1 2 3 4
5 you you choose Road two it's already
mentioned in advance in your destiny
that you will choose Road two it is not
because Allah is writing that you're
choosing it is because you will be
choosing that Allah has written in
advance so the choice is yours you have
a choice to earn your living whether
with good deeds Halal way or with
robbing Haram ways the choice is yours
now you
rob the choice was yours but Allah knows
in advance that this person he would
want easy money and he Rob so Allah has
WR in advance that this particular
person at the age of 25 he will rob
who's to blame you are to blame but
because Allah he has written in
advance the choice is yours Allah has
given us human beings free will you
cannot blame Allah subhana wa taala for
your
misdeeds if you go to hell it is because
of your misdeeds and if you go to Jenna
it is because of the grace of Allah
subhana wa
tala now let's try and answer this
question
the purpose of creation from a different
angle from the angle of the creation
from the angle from the perspective of
the human
being that why have the human beings
being created by almighty God and the
reply to this question is given in the
Quran in Sur chapter number 7 verse
number
172 and verse number 173 Allah says that
he brought out from the loins of Adam's
children may peace be upon him all the
descendants and ask them that am I your
lord and all said we testify that you
are our Lord and Allah continues lest on
the day of judgment they will say we
were unaware that you are our Lord or
lest they may say that our
ancestors they worshiped somebody else
they did shik they Associated partners
and we just followed them so they are
the liars we should not be blamed so
Allah subhana wa ta'ala before the human
beings came in this world Allah subhah
wa tala brought all the human beings
from the loins of the children of Adam
and asked them who is the Lord and all
of them testified that there's one Allah
subhana wa ta'ala and he's our Lord and
now is our test in this world Allah says
in the Quran and I started my talk by
quing the verse of the Quran from Surat
chapter number 51 verse number 56 Allah
says that we have created the Jin and
the men men not but to worship
me that we have created the Jin and the
men not but to worship me the purpose of
creation of the human beings and the Jin
is to worship Allah subhana wa taala now
this word
worship if you Analyze This English word
it is derived from the old English VOR
Skype which means to honor and if you
read
the new living Websters in Copic
dictionary it says that worship means
Act of
devotion honoring the
diety devotional acts honoring the
diet and if you translate into Arabic
the Arabic word
is the Arabic word for worship is I it
will derive from the root word ABD which
means
a slave and it the duty of the slave to
be obedient to all the wills and wishes
of the master so I means total
submission to the will of the Creator
Allah subhana wa taala IB means total
submission to the will and wishes of the
Creator Allah subhana wa ta'ala
and further if we analyze that even one
of the forms of worship as mentioned in
the English dictionary
is glorification as Allah says in the
Quran in Surah
anas chapter number 110 verse number
three Allah
says that means glorify the Praises of
the
Lord glorify the Praises of the Lord so
one form of worship is
glorification of the creat of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala and one may ask that
why does Allah subhana wa ta'ala require
the human beings to glorify
him is Allah subhana tala dependent on
the Praises of the human
beings see
irrespective if all the human beings
praise Allah subhana wa ta'ala it will
not make him Superior and if not a
single human being praise him yet it
will not diminish him he is the same
whether you say Allah abbar a thousand
times or million times it will not make
Allah greater or if you don't say Allah
abbar Al it will not make him
less he's the greatest he'll Remain the
greatest and Allah says in the Quran in
Surah F 35:15 that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
doesn't require the human beings it is
we who require him it the human beings
who require him and he's worthy of all
Praises Allah subhana does not require
his creation it is the Creations who
require Allah subhana wa taala and he's
worthy of all Praises so the question is
why does he require us to praise him the
reason is it is for our own
benefit because it is a human
tendency that if we praise a
person if a person is famous we tend to
follow his advice for
example if your mother is suffering from
a heart
problem and there are two options there
one option who you have is the best
doctor in the world number one very
famous everyone knows him number one
other person is just a plain mbbs doctor
and you have the option of going to any
of them both are giving free treatment
who will you go to but naturally go to
the one who's very famous number one in
the world the heart
specialist and whatever advice he gives
you because he's world famous and you
even acknowledge Him to be the greatest
amongst all the doctors you will follow
his advice that is the reason when we
praise Allah subhana wa T ta'ala and
call him he's the greatest he's the most
merciful he's the most kind the moment
we praise him whatever advice he has
given us in the last and final
Revelation the Glorious Quran or
whatever advice he has given us through
his
Messengers and the last and final
messenger Prophet MMI wasallam we will
follow it so the reason we praise him is
not for the benefit of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala he does not require Praises it is
for our own benefit the moment we praise
him oh he's the greatest he's the most
wise oh he's telling you not to have
alcohol then you stop having alcohol the
moment you agree that he's the most wise
he's the greatest he's the most merciful
immediately whatever advice he gives you
it human tendency we follow the advice
of the person who's the greatest so
that's the reason we praise him for our
own benefit and that's the reason Allah
says in the
Quran in Surah chapter number 20 verse
number 14 that
verily I am Allah subhana tala I am
Allah and there's no God besides
me so remember me regularly and offer
prayer
regularly Allah is guiding that offer
prayer regularly because today in the
world there are so many evil so many
distractions we tend to
deviate this Salah is a sort of
programming towards
righteousness this form of worship is a
programming towards righteousness we are
getting programmed as a doctor says that
for a healthy body you require minimum
three meals a day so for a pure soul for
a healthy Soul you require minimum five
times
Allah so all forms of worship are
benefit for us Allah says in the Quran
in Surah Bak chapter number two verse
number 183 that fasting has been
prescribed to you as it was prescribed
to those who came before you so that you
may learn
self-restraint why do we fast so that we
learn self-restraint and today the
psychology tell us that if you can
control your hunger you can control
almost all your desires so when we fast
fast we abstain from food drink from
dawn to Sunset if we can control our
hunger we can control almost all your
desires so by fasting we are worshiping
Allah subhana tala but who's benefiting
not Allah we are benefiting we are
learning to control our desires and
Allah says in the Quran in MA chapter
number five verse number
19 oh you who
believe most certainly intoxicant and
gambling dedic of stones divination of
arrows these are Satan's
handwork abstain from this handwork that
you may Prosper here we are being Guided
by Allah subhana wa ta'ala
that oh you believe most certainly
intoxicants gambling dedication of
stones that idol worship divination of
arrows that is fortune telling these are
Satan's hand work abstain from it that
you may prosper and Allah says in the
next verse in Surah MAA chapter number
five verse number 91 that Satan he
creates enemity and hatred between the
human beings through intoxicant and
gambling and this takes you away from
the remembrance of Allah subhana wa tala
so Allah is guiding you when you offer
Salah or when you read the Quran that's
a form of worship when offer Salah form
of worship you are getting guided that
steer away from intoxicants from
gambling it is a Satan who uses this to
create enmity between the human beings
and this will take you away from
remembrance of Allah subhana tala all
forms of worship any act any Commandment
that you follow of Allah subhana wa
taala is a form of worship any
commandment of Allah subhana wa tala
human being follows it's a form of
worship as long as you do it in the
right way there are two things there are
two criteria required number one is that
you should do it only for the pleasure
of Allah subhana wa taala and not for
your own glorification or praising your
own self any act you do you should do it
for the pleasure of Allah subhana wa
tala whatever Allah commands you do it
for his pleasure not for glorification
not for praise not for becoming famous
criteria number one criter number two
that it should be done the way Allah and
his messenger has commanded
you whatever Allah has asked you do it
the way Allah has asked you to do or the
way his messenger has asked you to do if
you do it in any other way that's not
called worship so do it for the sake of
Allah subhana tala follow his
Commandments and the Commandment of the
Prophet but the way Allah and his
Prophet have told you if you do it any
other way then it is not correct and
it's mentioned in the Hadith of the
Prophet mam in s
Muslim volume number two Hadith number
1885 where the Prophet mam said that the
worst of all the Affairs is innovation
in the religion innovation in Dean
it is a curse and the innovation in the
dean will take you to Hellfire mean the
worst of all the Affairs is
B in Dean innovation in Dean and this is
a curse and will take you towards the
Hellfire so whatever you do worship
there's a general
rule that all types of worship is
prohibited except the type which is
mentioned in the Quran and the say
Hadith the type which has been mentioned
by Allah and hiso any other type of
worship is prohibited it is forbidden
except that type of worship which has
been described in the Quran and
described in the S had of mamad
wasallam so further if we analyze that
the purpose of the creation of the human
being is to worship Allah subhana wa
ta'ala
and when we worship him we benefit it
helps us and there's a
misconception that Islam is a new
religion which came into existence 1400
years ago and Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon Him is the founder of this religion
of Islam in fact Islam is there since
time immemorial since man set foot on
this
Earth and Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
Him is not the founder of this religion
he's the last and final messenger of
Allah subhana wa tala there were several
Messengers that came as Allah says in
the Quran in Surah 35:4
there is not a nation or a tribe to whom
we have not sent a Warner or a guide
Allah says in number 13 verse number
7 and to every people has of hner been
sent there are more than 25 Messengers
mentioned by name in the Quran Adam Noah
Abraham Moses Jesus Muhammad peace be
upon them all all of them were
messengers of Allah subhana wa tala and
all of them they were Muslims Muslim
Muslim is a person who submits his will
to Allah subhana wa tala and Islam is a
word which comes from the root word
Salam which means peace or from Sal or
which means to submit your will to
almighty God so Islam in short means
peace acquired by submitting a will to
Allah subhana wa ta'ala to almighty God
the Creator all the messengers they
bought the same message and anyone who
submits his will to the create Allah
subhana wa ta'ala he's called as a
Muslim
Quran says in Surah Imran chapter number
3 verse number 52 that isaam Jesus
Christ peace be upon him he as a Muslim
Allah says in the Quran in Surah Al
Imran chapter number 3 verse number 67
that Abraham was not a Jew or a
Christian but he was a
Muslim and since our creator is one
humankind is one even the religion
should be
one that the reason Allah says in the
Quran inah Imran chapter number 3 verse
number 19 in the Islam the only religion
acceptable in the sight of Allah subhana
wa ta'ala it is Islam which is peace
acquired by submitting your will to
Allah subhana wa tala and Allah repeats
the message in Surah Al Imran chapter
number 3 verse number
85 that if anyone desires any other
religion besides Islam it will never be
accepted of him and in the he will be
among the
losers since our creator is one
humankind is one the religion is also
one and all the prophets teach the same
message of submitting your will to
almighty God worshiping him alone and no
one
else and Allah says in the
Quran in Sur B chapter number 98 verse
number
7 that those who have faith and do
righteous Deeds they are the best of
creation yeah Allah subhana wa ta'ala
calls the human beings the best of
creation the greatest there are many
greater creation like the heaven the
Earth but the best of creation is the
human being because we have a free will
and if with that free will we obey the
Commandment of Allah subhana wa ta'ala
we reach the best of creation highest we
are better even than the Angels because
Angel don't have a free will human
beings have a free will and then if you
obey the Commandment we become superior
to the angels but if you don't obey his
Commandments we become the brothers of
the
Satan so the human beings are the best
creation
of Allah subhana wa tala and the gravest
sin that described in the
Quran Ina chap number four verse number
48 that Allah subhana wa ta'ala will
forgive anything Allah subhana wa taala
if he pleases he will forgive anything
sin but the sin of shik he'll never
forgive Allah repeats the message inaha
chapter number four verse number 116
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala if he
pleases he will forgive any sin but the
sin of associating part partners with
him he shall never forgive the greatest
sin for the human being is associating
partners with Allah subhana wa tala
worshiping anyone besides the one true
God Allah subhana wa taala and one of
the qualities of Allah subhana taala is
love and as I mentioned that Allah
subhana wa ta'ala he loves his
creation and because he loves us with
his
grace he has given us all this n
all the N that is given us the air that
we breathe the water that we drink all
the
facilities that Allah has given us
because he loves us and those who obey
his Commandments he has prepared A Place
For Us in Paradise in the next life also
this is because of his love the Beloved
Prophet mamm wasallam said it's
mentioned in s
Muslim Vol number one Hadith number 67
that that person
has tasted the sweetness of the faith
those who do three things number one
those who love those who love Allah and
his messenger more than everyone in the
world number two those who love human
beings or those who love people for the
sake of Allah subhana wa ta'ala and
number three those who hate to go back
to disbelief from where Allah saved them
and they don't want to go to the
Hellfire so these people who do these
three things according to the Hadith of
mammad Salli wasallam they have tasted
the true sweetness of
faith and as Allah mentioned in the
Quran in Surah Al Imran chapter number 3
verse number 31 the prophet is commanded
to say that all those who love Allah
follow me for Allah will love you and
Allah will forgive
you now if he analyze that we human
beings we too love the other human
beings we love our parents Our Father
father and mother we love our wives we
love our
children and the reason we love them
basically is because these people these
human beings have done certain favor on
us for example we love our mother
because she bore us in a womb for 9
months she took care of us in childhood
she bought us up we love our brothers
either they have given us something or
we want something from them we love the
human beings so in that context
if you
calculate the favors Allah has done on
us Allah says in the Quran in Surah
ibraim chapter number 14 verse number 34
that if you count the favors of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala you will not be able
to add them up so imagine if we love our
parent for the few things they have
given us how much should we love Allah
subhana wa
tala and the love differs we human
beings we even love
animals we love human beings also but
the love of the animals that the human
beings have is different on a different
level as compared to the love that we
have for the human beings similarly the
love for Allah subhana wa ta'ala
is on a different level as compared to
the love we have for the human beings it
is far superior it is far more on a
higher
platter it is mentioned in the Quran in
Surah FAA chapter number one verse
number
five alone we worship the alone we for
help we have to only worship him and no
one else Allah says in Surah GA chapter
number 40 verse number 60 you ask me and
I will answer your prayer Allah says in
Surah Bak chapter number two verse
number
186 oh messenger when they ask you about
me tell them I'm near to them and I will
answer their
prayers so all worship should only be
done to Allah subhana wa ta'ala and no
one else he is the only one who deserves
the worship and no one else now let us
analyze the purpose of creation from
another perspective from the perspective
of the human beings that what is the
purpose of existence in this
world God created
us we came in this world what is our
requirement what is our purpose of
existence and Allah gives the reply in
Sur mul chapter number 67 verse number
two Allah
says it's Allah who has created death
and life to test which of you good deeds
Allah has created death and life to test
which of you good in
deeds and Allah says in the Quran in
Imran chapter number 3 verse number 185
Allah
says every soul shall have a taste of
death but the final recompense will be
on the day of judgment and anyone who
has been saved from the fire and enters
the garden he would have achieved the
objective of this world for this world
is nothing but mere chattles of
deception that means this life of our in
this world is a test for the Hereafter
if you obey the Commandments of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala in the next life we'll
get Paradise if you don't obey we will
not get Paradise we'll go to hell so
this life the purpose of existence as
Allah says is the test for the hereafter
and Allah says in the Quran in anab
chapter number 29 verse number two that
do you think just by saying we believe
we will let you go we will surely test
you mean if you just say I believe in
Allah I am a Muslim I am a m do you
think Allah will let you go finish your
test is over Allah say don't you think
we will test you just by saying I a
Muslim just by saying you're a Believer
just by saying I submit my will to
almighty God you will not go free Allah
will surely test you and Allah says in
the Quran in Surah Bak chapter number 2
verse number
155 that surely we will test you with
fear and hunger with loss of your lives
and of the goods and what you've
accumulated in your life and give Glad
Tidings to those who are patient Allah
says he'll test everyone either with
fear or with Hunger or with loss of life
or with Goods or the wealth of
accumulated Allah will test
you and Allah test different people in
different ways and Allah says in the
Quran in Anam chapter number 6 verse
number 165 Allah says that he has given
more sustainance to some of the human
beings over the other with some of the
human beings Allah subhana wa ta'ala has
given more sustainance as compared to
the other Allah says this in Surah Nel
chapter number 16 verse number 71 that
he has favored some of of the human
beings over others in
sustainance Allah repeats this message
in Surah Anam chapter number 6 verse 165
that Allah subhana wa ta'ala has given
more
gifts to some of the individuals and
based on what he has given you he will
test you now there's a question that
people ask that how can Allah subhana
tala be just that some people are born
in a poor family some people are born in
a rich family some people are bornn
healthy some people are born with
diseases it is unjust Allah subhana wa
tala is unjust how can he make the
differentiation between different human
beings we come to know that this
world has life and
death there is health and
disease There Is wealth and poverty all
these are
tests and Allah says in the Quran in
Surah anfal chapter number 8 verse
number 28 Allah says that
that surely your wealth and your preny
your children are a test for
you and Allah says in chapter number 63
verse number n that let not the wealth
and your children deviate you from the
remembrance of Allah subhana wa ta'ala
Allah subhah wa ta'ala test different
people in different
way one of the test one of the best deed
you ask anyone that what are the good
deeds and the Good Deeds that all human
beings whether they believe in God or
not they'll say the Good Deeds are
charity it is contentment charity will
be there amongst the few that he names
so how can almighty God test whether
some people are charitable or not if all
the people have the same wealth then
where is the question of the test the
test will only take place if some people
are poor and some people are rich so
Allah subhana wa taala test people in
different
ways maybe some people are born in a
rich family they have a lot of wealth
some people are born poor but the person
who is Rich according to the Islamic
Sharia one of the pillars of Islam is
zakat that every rich person who has a
saving of more than the nisab level 85
grams of gold he or she should give 2.5%
of that saving every Luna year in
charity the person may be a millionaire
may be a
billionaire he may give the required
amount then he will get passing marks he
may not give the complete amount he may
give portion small portion maybe 20% of
what is required to give a part of what
is required to give he will fail some
people may not give zakat at
all absolutely fail the poor person he
does not have to give zakat at all he
gets full marks but we hum we say oh b
poor man you know so much problems he
has in his life and we look up to the
person who's
rich our beloved Prophet
said that it is more difficult for a
rich man to enter jna than a poor man
but as the Quran says in Surah anal
8:28 that the wealth is a test for you
it's a
test we are fools that we think okay you
know this person is Rich Allah has
blessed
him it's a
test if he doesn't use the blessings
which Allah has given him it's a
blessing but the chances of him failing
the test is very high for example in one
of the question papers which came last
year or two years before in 2002
a very difficult question
came and most of the student could not
reply next year that question does not
appear it would be foolish for us to say
oh how sad this question did not come
you should be happy it did not come so
wealth is a test so those people who
don't have wealth it is actually easier
for them to go to Jenna than a rich
man so Allah test different people in
different ways therefore Allah says that
let not your wealth deviate you from the
remembrance of Allah subhana wa tala
it's a test for
him the other test it is
contentment it's contentment and a
beloved Prophet M wasallam
said it's mentioned
inkari number8 Hadith number
447 the prophet said that even if a
person owns a value of gold he would
want to have another even if a person
owns a value of gold he would want to to
own another Valley of gold and the
maximum he can take in his mouth is the
dirt of the
Grave however Rich he is let him be the
richest man in the world the person
would want to Crave for more
wealth a person is not content most of
the human beings aren't
content Allah says in the Quran inaha
chapter number 4 verse number 32 that do
not ask from Allah subhana wa ta'ala
that which Allah has favored other
people we say know Allah subhana tala
you have given him so much wealth you
have given him such a good beautiful car
don't ask from Allah what Allah has
favored others
with it will be lost for you and our
beloved propham said it's mentioned in s
bukari Vol number four our beloved
Prophet said that look at those people
who are less fortunate than
you don't look at those people who are
more fortunate than you lest it will
divert you from the remembrance of Allah
subhana tala lest you may be ungrateful
to your lord so Prophet said look at
those who are less fortunate then you
see okay fine the person you know he
doesn't have a car at least I have a
small car maruti car don't look at a
person having a Mercedes oh why don't I
have a Mercedes the person doesn't have
a car at least Allah has given me a car
you be thankful to Allah the moment you
compare yourself with the person who has
a Mercedes oh why isn't Allah given me a
Mercedes look at those people who are
less fortunate it will help you to
remember Allah subhana wa tala and this
is human nature and they seeing that
there was a man who complained because
he had no shoes until he saw a man who
had no
feet a person used to complain have got
no shoes complain to Allah I've got no
shoes and he saw a man who had no feet
then he's thanking Allah subhana tala at
least I have feet so
contentment is a test our beloved
Prophet M wasallam said it's mentioned s
bukari why number eight that the real
wealth is contentment it is not property
the real true wealth is contentment
being satisfied whatever you have you
say alhamdulillah praise be to Allah
that is the true M that's a True
Believer that's a true Muslim
contentment while people ask that how
come Allah subhana wa ta'ala
has created some people who are born
healthy he makes some people born
healthy some people are born with
diseases
maybe conal disease heart disease some
handicap so is Allah unjust Allah says
in the Quran Ina 4:40 Allah subhah wa
ta'ala is never unjust in the least
degree this is a test Allah tests
different people different ways maybe
it's possible the children that are born
they are mum they sinless it's not their
fault at all but as the Quran says in
Surah anfal chapter number 8 verse
number 28 that your wealth and your
children are a test for you and Allah
repeats the message in chapter 63 verse
number n that do not let your wealth and
your children deviate from the
remembrance of Allah subhana wa tala so
may be possible that it's a test for the
parents it's a test for the
parents there may be occasion whenever
any Calamity comes on any individual it
is either a test or it's a
punishment those people who have
deviated from Allah subhana wa ta'ala
for them it's a punishment from those
who on the true par is a test for
them maybe the parents are very good
Muslims offering five times Salah may
have given the zakat may have gone for
HUD maybe fasting the month of Ramadan
now Allah gives them a child who has
conal heart disease the true Muslim a
true M will say alhamdulillah thank you
Allah subhana tala Allah is testing them
a person who's ungrateful or may not be
able to pass the difficult test will say
oh why he will start cribbing he'll
complain to Allah subhana tala why did
Allah give me a child who handicapped
who has congenital heart
disease and more difficult the test more
high is the
reward more difficult is the test more
higher is the reward for example if you
sit for a ba degree
examination if you pass you're
graduate ba graduate in arts but if you
pass and mbbs examination besides being
a graduate you get a doctor in front of
your name doctor but to pass mbbs
examination is multiple times more
difficult than to pass a b
examination so more difficult the test
more higher is the reward so maybe Allah
subhana wa ta'ala wants to give those
parents not J but J so even though they
pass Allah wants to give them a higher
reward and that the reason a beloved
Prophet Muhammad sahi wasallam said it's
mentioned when a person asked that who
had the maximum test in this world the
prophet replied that all theas all the
prophets of Allah subhana wa ta'ala they
had the most difficult test after that
those who are closest to them those who
are like the prophets after that those
who are like
them and more higher is the faith of a
person more difficult is a test mean
more Tak person has Allah gives you a
difficult test see you took admission
into mbbs because you got high marks in
12th standard hi so more difficult test
to pass mbbs a difficult so here also
the prophets that TAA level cannot be
compared with the normal human beings so
just because they were prophets of God
even the prophets were tested no Prophet
was just LED without testing but because
the tawa was high the prophets were
tested multiple times more than the
normal human being life compared to you
and me more difficult so more higher is
your tawa and the faith Allah will test
You So True Believer if difficulty comes
he says say ah Subhan Allah praise be to
Allah
alhamdulillah he takes it as a test any
Calamity comes it's either a test or a
punishment for the prophets of high tawa
it wasn't a punishment it was a test and
they pass the test when any good things
happen to an individual it's either a
reward or a
test wealth can be a reward or it can be
a test for you any good thing happens it
is either a reward or a test for you for
those who have deviated from Allah
subhana tala they pray give me wealth
Allah give them wealth and tell them and
they fail so in this world they get what
they want luxury but in the it's nothing
but
loss charity is a test contentment is
the
test the children are a
test many of time we human beings We
complain to Allah subhana wa taala we
are praying to Allah subhana wa tala why
doesn't Allah answer our prayer Allah
says in the Quran you ask me and I will
answer your prayer but here I'm praying
every day Allah is not answering it
sounds B contradictory Allah says you
pray too men answer your prayer but we
find many we pray but nothing happens
Allah says in the Quran in Surah Bak
chapter number two verse number 26 you
may like a thing which is not good for
you and you may hate a thing which is
good for you you know not but Allah
knows for
example there is a young boy about 20
years old he's praying Ya Allah subhana
tal give me a BMW I don't know aware of
BMW BMW motorcycle I want a BMW
motorcycle very fast motorcycle praying
praying praying prayer is not answered
maybe Allah knows that if Allah would
have given him a motorcycle he would
have had an accident and he would have
factured his leg he would have become
handicapped so actually Allah subhana wa
ta'ala by not answering his prayer he's
answering his
Prayer by not answering his prayer Allah
is answering his prayer
by not giving him a motorcycle because
he's a good
B he's a good person he's asking for
things which is not good for him I know
he doesn't know so Allah doesn't give so
by not answering Allah is answering and
many of times people like Allah says in
Surah Bak chapter 2 verse number 15 and
16 about the Hypocrites he says that
Allah gives them rope so that they go to
and fro you ask wealth Allah gives them
wealth there are many people who
associate partners with Allah they ask I
want wealth Allah gives them wealth it
is nothing but a test for them and they
are digging their own Graves so we
should never
despair Allah is there always have faith
in Allah subhana tala that's the reason
suicide is Haram in the Quran it's
mentioned chap 4 that kill not
yourself kill not yourself because Allah
is most forgiving he's there if you have
faith in him the moment a person commits
suicide it is as though he's ungrateful
he says almighty God has given me so
much trouble he is unjust it's not worth
living any ends his life Allah says in
the Quran in Surah Bak chapter number
two verse number 286 which is the last
verse of Surah Bak that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala does not lay a burden on
anyone greater than what he can bear
Allah does not lay a burden on anyone
greater than what he can
bear this is the first part of the verse
the next part of the verse continues and
then we make a Dua Ya Allah subhana tala
lay not on us a burden greater than we
can bear in the first part of the verse
when Allah has already promised that he
will not lay a burden greater than what
we can bear then why do we have to pray
oh Lord lay not on us a burden greater
than we can be because why we dig our
own grave we lay a burden greater then
what we can bear we are the cause we ask
give me wealth Allah gives
wealth so we are praying to Allah
subhana wa taala make not us the cause
to lay a burden on ourself greater than
we can be so we should always have faith
in Allah subh wa tala and worship him
alone he is the creator our purpose of
existence is to worship Allah subhana
tala and no one else this life is a test
for the Hereafter obey his Commandments
and be satisfied whatever test he gives
you a true moment is thankful to Allah
subhana wa tala normally We complain we
don't have this we don't have this the
most important thing for living is
what someone tells food someone say
water most important is air if you don't
have air for a few minutes you will die
how many of us have you ever thanked
Allah subhana tala thank you for the air
you have given us how many of us have
done that how many of us do we realize
free we should reflect on the signs of
Allah subhana wa tala and all the N he
has given
us now coming to the last
perspective that why did Allah subhana
wa ta'ala create this world what is the
purpose of this world Allah says in the
Quran in Surah ibraim chapter number 14
verse number 32 33 that Allah subhana wa
taala has created the Heaven and the
Earth and let water come from the sky
with it he has given fruits he has
caused the ship to sail with the
Commandment of Allah subhana tala he has
called rivers to flow for the human
beings he has made the sun and the moon
for you he has made the night and the
day for you so all this Creation in the
world are for the human beings the full
world Allah has created is for the human
beings and it is our
duty that we have to thank Allah subhana
wa ta'ala for all these
n and besides thanking it's our duty
that we take care of these things that's
the reason Allah subhana wa tala has
created animals but killing
animals it is
prohibited killing animals is prohibited
it's mention of Mami wasallam that do
not kill animals for target practice yes
for food amongst the Halal animal which
Allah has given
permission that you can have with the
way Allah has showed you and the prophet
has showed us but for target practice
and we find many people they want to
conquer these Nama they do target
practice and they want to put the head
of the animal in the drawing room Allah
has created the mountains we want to
conquer the mountains go on mountain
Everest how many people die every year
in trying to climb the mount ever you
want to conquer it we don't to thank
Allah subhana tala for the
N even though Allah says in the Quran
the camels have been created for you to
carry load but even though they have
been created for you we have to love
them we have to respect them there are
several say several it's mentioned
inkari volume number
three that there's a person who gave
water to a Thirsty Dog by going in the
well by carrying the water in the socks
and because of that he was gone to jna
there's another inkari number four that
there was a prostitute just because she
gave water a Thirsty Dog she was guned
Jenna and a sahaba asked that do we get
reward even for giving water to a dog he
said yes why not imagine the animal
which is prohibited to come in our house
even if you give water to that animal
Allah will reward you for
that and there's a Hadith that once an
old lady she tied a cat and did not give
give it food so Allah put her in hell
that why did shean did not give her food
at least she should have let it go free
she would have fed on the rodents and
that poster is there in one of the
posters that is in the exhibition so we
have to even love and take care of the
animals even the vegetations we can eat
them for a requirement but not
unnecessary kill the plants even in war
a prophet M wasam said that do not chop
down trees do not burn the crops so all
these are the creations of Allah subhana
wa
tala and Allah says in the Quran in
Sur chapter number 100 Allah says Allah
takes an oath of the steeds of
war the horses that done for war Allah
is taking oath and saying Allah
continues verse number 1 2 3 4 Allah
says that these horses Sparks come out
of the Hooves clouds of dust they raise
they enter the
enemy describing that Allah is taking an
oath of these horses the states of War
they are without any fear just because
the master commands them the person who
the horse rider for the sake of the
master they enter into the enemy there
are swords there are weapons
irrespective whether the weapons the
stre keeps on going because he wants to
obey the master Allah is taking oath of
this
F and in the ending he says but man is
ungrateful that means the horse to obey
the master it is ready to die is ready
to get itself killed just because the
master says go it goes whether there the
enemy whether the sword whether the
weapon whether they're going towards the
death because of the master but human
beings are very
ungrateful that's the reason is the duty
of every human being to
reflect on the purpose of
creation that why have we been created
Allah subhana wa ta'ala he's the
Creator he's merciful he's kind he's
forgiving he's just it's the duty of
every human being that you should
worship Allah subhana wa ta'ala worship
him and no one else and this life you
have to remember is a test for the
Hereafter if you follow his Commandments
we should go to jenah if you don't we
shall fail this test and go to jahannam
and we have to take care of the N Allah
has given us us I'd like to end my talk
by giving the quotation of the Glorious
Quran from Surah Al Imran chapter number
three verse number 110 which
says oh Muslims ye are the best of
people evolve for mankind we are called
as the best of people Whenever there is
honor it is always for the
responsibility there's no honor without
responsibility the responsibility is
mentioned the same verse and Allah
continues
because we enjoy what is good and we
forbid what is wrong and we believe in
Allah it's the duty of every Muslim that
whatever he knows if you know the
purpose of creation you have to tell it
to the others by we created we should
worship no one but Allah subhana wa tala
this life is a test for the yearafter
invite people to the truth exalt them to
the
truth and enjoin them towards the good
and prevent them from going towards
wrong it's the duty of every Muslim dawa
is compulsory if we do not enjoy what is
good and we do not prevent people going
towards the wrong we aren't fit to be
called as Muslims we aren't fit to be
called as the best of people I would
like to my talk with the quotation of
the Quran from 16 vers 125 he
says invite all to the way of th Lord
with wisdom and beautiful preaching and
argue with them and reason with them in
the ways that are best most gracious
walk
Al Now we move on to the question and
answer session before we begin let me
lay down The rules so that we can have
the session in a very smooth
fashion please form a Queue at one of
the four mics provided to you one mic is
in the ladies section there are three
mics in the Gent section one at the
backside one on my right and one here on
my left
while posing the questions please state
your name and
profession please note that this is a
question time not a lecture time so be
precise and to the point when you pose
your question I request the volunteers
who are handling the mic to give
preference to our non-muslim brothers
who would be in the queue while posing
the question please bring the non-muslim
brothers at the front preference is
given to the non-muslim brothers to POS
the
questions good evening Dr Zakir my name
is Roberto I'm doing BDS in chenai
Savita Dental College as Dr Sagi said
God is a unique Creator there is only
one second thing you said God created
Human by out of love third God has
created wealth poor healthy and weakness
is all because of a test similarly in
Christian
they believe God is one second Point God
created human out of love third point is
the same thing all this things is
because of a test by the God so I just
want to have an answer from you don't
mistake I'm not a Christian the brother
as a
question that even in Christianity like
Islam God is one and God loves loves the
creation and he further said then what
is the
difference you want know the difference
between Islam and Christianity or it's
not the difference what is the most
convinced thing you think that you say
that other than Islam any other type of
worship is non-acceptable that's a very
good question the brother now the
question has come to forth that first
there was just blank statements if a
question mark it's a question if it a
statement we have to try and find the
question what is the difference between
Islamic form of worship as compared to
other form of worship what is so unique
when Christianity also says God is one
Christianity says that God also loves
Islam says God is one Islam says God
also loves the creation Islam says
worship Christianity says worship what
is the difference between the worship of
Islam and Christianity or what is the
uniqueness about Islam as compared to
other religions mainly talking about
Christianity brother on the face of it
if you
read the Quran correctly and the
interpretation I gave in my talk
and if you read the Bible correctly with
the correct interpretation we believe
that Jesus Christ peace be upon him he
was one of the mightiest messengers of
Allah subhana wa tala no muslim as a
Muslim if he does not believe in Jesus
Christ peace be upon him we believe that
he was born miraculously without any
male intervention we believe that he was
the Messiah translated Christ we believe
that he healed those born blind and
lepers is God's permission we believe
that he gave life to the Dead with God's
permission
but there are parting of fa there are
many
Christians who say that Jesus Christ
peace be upon him he claimed
Divinity now the difference between what
the Bible says and the difference
between what the Christians
assume and what they practice the
difference between that so many
Christians say that Jesus Christ PE be
he claim Divinity so when they say God
is one they say Jesus Christ peace be
upon Him With God which we Muslims take
objection to there is not a single
unequivocal statement in the complete
Bible where Jesus Christ peace be upon
him himself says that I am God or where
he says worship me so the form of
worship for the normal Christian is
worshiping Jesus Christ peace be upon
him and I repeat my statement there is
not a single unequal statement in the
complete Bible where Jesus Christ peace
be upon himself says that I am God or
where he says worship me if any
Christian can show me any unequivocal
statement in the Bible where Jesus
Christ peace be upon Him says I am God
or where he says worship me I Dr Zakir n
I'm ready to accept Christianity today
I'm ready to put my head on the
guillotine I don't speak on behalf of my
other Muslim brothers because if you
read the Bible it is mentioned in the
Gospel of John chapter number 14 verse
number 28 Jesus Christ peace be upon you
said that my father is greater than I
Gospel of John chapter number 10 verse
number 29 my father is greater than All
gospel of Matthew chapter number 12
verse number 28 I with the spirit of God
cast out devil Gospel of Luke chapter
number 11 verse vers number 20 I with
the Finger of God cast out devil Gospel
of John chapter number 5 verse number 30
I can of my own self do nothing as I
hear I judge and my judgment is just for
I seek not my will but the will of my
father anyone who says I seek not my
will but the will of almighty God he's a
Muslim therefore I said in my talk that
Jesus Christ peace be upon him was a
Muslim Quran says that in Surah Al Imran
3:52 it's further mentioned in the
Gospel of John chapter number 17 verse
number three this is life eternal so
that you may know Jesus Christ whom thou
has sent it's mentioned in the Gospel of
John chapter number 14 verse number 24
the words you hear are not mine but my
fathers who have sent me it's clearly
mentioned in the book of Acts chapter
number 2 verse number 22 e men of Israel
listen to this Jesus of Nazareth a man
approved of God amongst You by wonders
and miracles which God did by him and
you a witness to it a man approved of
God amongst You by wonders and miracles
which God did by him and you witness to
it so Jesus Christ peace be upon him was
one of the mightiest messengers of God
but he never claimed
he never said you should worship me but
unfortunately the Christian church today
they teach that
salvation Bible also talks about heaven
talks about hell but the purpose of
existence is not mentioned in detail
it's not mentioned at all except what
Paul has
mentioned Paul mentioned in
Corinthians chapter number 15 he says in
the First Corinthians chapter number 15
that if Jesus Christ peace be upon Him
died not for your sins your faith is in
vain and everything is in vain that
means Jesus Christ peace be upon him he
died for your sins according to Paul and
they
quote the verse of the Bible Gospel of
John chapter number 3 verse number 16
that for God so of the world that he
gave his only begotten son whosoever
believeth in him shall not die but have
everlasting life so the concept of
salvation according to the church is
that you believe Jesus Christ peace be
up and died for your sins and you shall
go to Jenna you shall go to Paradise
which is not mentioned because the word
begotten from Gospel of John chapter
number 3 vers number 16 has been thrown
out by THU scholar of the highest
Eminence from the RSV revised stand
version of the Bible as a concoction as
a fabrication as an interpolation so
what they're following is more of poline
Christianity but Jesus Christ peace be
upon him said when a person approaches
him in the gospel of Matthew chapter
number 19 verse number 16 and 17 that
good Master what good things shall I do
so that I shall gain eternal life what
good things shall I do so that I shall
go to Jenna Paradise so Jesus Christ
peace be upon replies why thou callest
me good there is none good except one
that is almighty God and if thou want to
enter eternal life you follow the
Commandments he didn't say that if you
want to go to Jenna want to go to
paradise you believe I died for your
sins he never said that he said follow
the Commandments and Jesus Christ PE be
him said it's mentioned in the gospel of
Matthew chapter number five verse number
17- 20 that think not that I am come to
destroy the law of the prophets I have
come not to destroy but
fulfill unless the heavens and the Earth
pass away not one J or shall be passed
away from the law until all be fulfilled
and whosoever shall keep the
Commandments and teach men to do so
shall be called great in the kingdom of
heaven and whosoever shall break one of
the least Commandments will be called Le
in the Kingdom of Heaven unless your
righteousness exceeds the righteousness
of the scribes and the Pharisees in no
way shall you enter into Paradise is if
you want to be a good Christian you have
to follow all the Commandments there's
only one God you should not do idol
worship all what Moses peace be upon
himself said so here we analyze if we do
a research of the biblical scriptures it
is actually believing in one God not
Trinity Allah says in the Quran in 4:
171 don't say
trinity has stop it's better for you so
if you say God is three in one it is sh
you won't get salvation there's no
statement at all about Trinity the word
Trinity does not exist anywhere in the
Bible but is there in the Quran besides
Sur 4: 171 it's also there in Sur ma
chapter number 5 verse number 73 it
says they are doing they are blaspheming
those who say that God is three in one
the word Trinity doesn't exist anywhere
in the Bible the closest statement is
the first Epistle of John chapter number
5 verse number 7 which says for there
are three that bear aord in heaven the
Father the Son and the Holy Ghost and
these three are one and this verse of
the Bible by tidu Scholars of the
highest time in Christian scholars in
the revised Standard Version of the
Bible they've thrown this verse out of
the Bible as interpolation as a
fabrication as a concoction so the verse
which come closest to the Trinity
doesn't mention Trinity but comes
closest is thrown out by the scholars of
Christianity as a fabrication so if we
analyze if you want to check what is
right in the Bible here is the fan this
is the criteria it will tell you what is
right what is wrong and if you compare
with this and even today if you read the
Bible the Bible never claims that Jesus
is God peace be upon him it says you
should worship only one God and when
Jesus Christ peace be upon us asked that
which is the first of The Commandments
it's mentioned in the gospel of Mark
number 12 verse number 29
says it's a Hebrew qu which means is the
Lord our God is one Lord so the problem
is that if you read the Bible the exact
purpose of creation is not mentioned it
is vague the Christian church has taken
up a teaching of Paul St Paul and says
that you believe Jesus Christ peace but
died for your sins and you will go to
heaven then you do anything you rob you
rape you do anything if he's paid for
our sins if Jesus Christ peace be and
paid for our sins I Can Do
Anything For example someone tells me to
a restaurant go to the restaurant eat
what you want I paid your bill I can eat
anything chicken mutton Biryani anything
I can eat so if Jesus Christ peace be
upon him I died for my sins then you can
commit any sin and you'll go to heaven
only have to believe that he died for
your sins so this is a concept of the
church which is not what the Bible
mentions and you can refer to my video
cassette similarities between Islam and
Christianity which gives the
similarities that's the reason I say
that Jesus Christ taught nothing but
Islam that is submitting a will to
almighty
[Applause]
God can we have the next question from
brother over here please state your name
in profession as well retired super n at
the outset I am extremely delighted to
be here even though I am not a
Muslim in the Old Testament of the Bible
it is noted as that God created the day
and night in the first day after that
God created the Sun and the Moon how is
it possible for the day and night
without the sun likewise in Quran it is
mentioned that the sun rotates the
Earth as per chap 21 verse
22 of Quran God controls the universe my
doubt is as to whether
God had mistaken when he creates the
Universe I think the contents in the
Bible and Quran are against his signs
please explain brother can I have your
name and can you repeat what is about
the Quran I didn't you heard correctly
your name first and what do you mention
about the Quran Quran says that the sun
rot Quran in Surah number six I think
Quran number six the sun rotates you
said 21 22 chapter 21 vers 22 chapter
number 21 ver 22 the sun rotates no in
Surah number six I think but in chap 21:
22 God controls the
universe so that goes against science
yes Brothers asked a question he said
that he has read the Bible he quoted a
few verses of the Bible and of the Quran
didn't give the reference he said that
the Bible says that almighty God created
day and the night in the F the what is's
quoting is the first book of the Bible
the Book of Genesis chapter number one
verse number three it's says that
almighty God created the day and the
night and on the first day and further
if you read in Genesis chapter number
one verse number 13 to 19 it says
almighty God created the sun on the
fourth day I'm giving you the references
also so doesn't this go against science
I do agree with you it goes against
science and I had a debate with Dr
William Campbell in USA Dr William
Campbell he is a missionary and a
medical doctor and got a PhD writing
against the Quran and in that debate on
the Quran and the Bible and the light of
science even I posed this question even
he couldn't answer so I do agree there's
a problem in the
Bible now coming to a question that the
Quran says that almighty God controls
the universe regarding the Bible yes I
do agree with you Bible is against
established science regarding a question
that Quran says almighty God controls
the universe you didn't say that sun
rotates rotates
ah that that's what I heard therefore
I'm asking you to repeat why aren't you
repeating I heard that and it gave
reference chapter 21 verse 22 the
reference is wrong the real reference is
I'll tell you the real reference is Sur
Amia 21:33 not 22 vers 33 yes the Quran
I'm speaking from memory I'm not a
computer I'll give the reply brother
after I reply whatever query you have no
problem brother you asked brother you
asked the question let me reply after I
finish my reply you can ask another 20
questions but you ask the question I was
listening to you carefully Now you
listen to my answer and after I finish
my answer if you have any query you can
ask I will give you enough time even
chairman doesn't agree I'll request him
to give you time because you are
delighted to come here we are more
delighted that you are
here the brother said that the Quran
says in Surah Amia CH 21 verse 22 it's
actually verse 33 that the sun rotates
what is quoting in the verse of the
Quran ofia 21:33 he says
it is Allah who has created night and
the
day and the
moon each one tring orbit with his own
motion and this mistake was even taken
out by T you know Tas heard of her ah
from Bangladesh she said that if a book
believe that the sun rotates around the
earth then how can we advance so the
Quran has to be
changed the problem is that a view
should be changed and she should read
the Quran correctly the Quran says
it is Allah who has created the night
and the day the Sun and the
Moon each one traveling in orbit with
its own motion nowhere does the Quran
say that the sun rotates or revolves
around the earth nowhere what does the
Quran say the Sun and the Moon rotate
and revolve nowhere does it say around
the earth the word Earth is not there in
this verse it
says it is Allah who has created night
and
day the Sun and the Moon
each one traveling Orit with his own
motion when I was in school I had
learned that the sun was
stationary it did not rotate about his
own axis it revolved in the universe the
old solar system is revolving but I when
I passed my school 1982 I had learned
the sun was stationary not rotate but
this verse of the Quran says the Arabic
word yesun is derived from the word
sabaha which describes the motion of a
moving body if I use this Arabic word
sabaha for a person on the floor it will
not mean he's rolling it will mean he's
walking around
if I use this Arabic word for a person
in the water it will not mean he's
floating it will mean he's swimming when
Allah uses this word for a Celestial
body it doesn't mean it's flying it
means it is rotating about its own axis
so Quran says the Sun and the Moon
besides revolving they also rotating
about the own axis when I read the ver
of the Quran I said but I read in my
school book the sun does not rotate
today science has advanced and we come
to know we can have the image of the sun
on a tabletop and we see that the sun
has got black spots and these black
spots take about 25 days to complete one
notation indicating the sun takes
approximately 25 days to complete one
notation so what I learned in school in
1982 today s says it is wrong Quran has
mentioned this not 20 years back 1400
years back what I learned in school 20
years
back the Quran says what I learned is
wrong first I got a shock but then I did
more research I realize that the Quran
is Right Quran is not wrong my science
book was
wrong and T where did she put the word
Earth inside I don't know does she know
Arabic can she read English English
translation doesn't say that she assumed
that when the Quran says that sun
revolves it revolves around the earth
that's assumption so her assumption is
wrong alhamdulillah Quran is not
wrong and I do agree with you that Allah
subhana wa ta'ala he controls this
universe that's the reason according to
Francis Bacon Francis b a great
philosopher he said little knowledge of
science makes you an atheist but indepth
knowledge of science makes you a
believer in one God hope that answer the
[Applause]
question do you have another question
you have any question most welcome if
you have any counter question you're
most welcome brother we love you sir I'm
not sure the a number no problem I I
never criticized you I just corrected
you did I tell I have to just tell the
right thing if you have given something
wrong reference if someone open that
corrected you I didn't say that you have
to know by heart neither are you
computer neither am I a computer but I
think it is in the Surah number eight I
think the sun is rotating Earth it's
nowhere in the Quran I'm telling you the
verse you're quoting is Surah Amia 21:33
even quoted by and hundreds of critics
of Islam No Way in Sur anal chapter 8
does it say that the sun no way in the
Quran it says the sun rotates the
closest misunderstanding you can have if
you don't know Arabic or don't read the
transl correctly is Sur so your first
reference was very close only 11 verses
different so your reference was right
chapter number was right 21 but the
verse was not 22 it was verse 33 here is
the Quran
no chapter number 21 verse 22 the God
controls the
universe now one more the God controls
the universe that's why I'm telling you
science hasn't Advanced so far to come
to know about the reality of Allah
subhana wa tala I've given the talk is
the Quran God's word and have proved
scientifically the existence of Allah
subhana tala I would request one of the
volunteers to present my video cassette
to him I request brother that you can
ask one of the volunteers I'll give you
a gift a video cassette is the Quran
God's word which has mentioned several
scientific facts and has even proved
scientifically the existence of Allah
subhana wa tala therefore today
scientist top scientists are not
eliminating God they are not the
eliminating models of God they are not
eliminating God but eliminating models
of
God you understand so today scientist
top scientist in the world they all
believe in God most some may have
deviated but most of them agree there
has to be a Creator about the creation
of the universe today science tells us
how did the universe come into creation
how by The Big Bang correct yes very
good big bang that today scientists they
tell us that first there was a primary
nebula the whole universe then there was
secondary separation a big bang which
gave rise to galaxies which gave rise to
Stars the planets the Sun the moon and
the Earth we live in this is called the
Big Bang when did you come to know about
this big bang 20 years back 30 years
back 40 years back correct Allah says in
the Quran in Surah Amia chapter number
21 verse number 30 Allah says 1400 years
ago Allah says that do not the
unbeliever see that the heavens and the
Earth were joined together do not the
unbeliever
see that the heavens and the Earth were
joined together and we clo them Mund so
Allah says that the heavens and the
Earth were join together and we clo them
us under this big b was today the
scientist talk about is mentioned in the
Quran 1400 years back in a nutshell who
could have mentioned this that time
science was in advanced who the Creator
so like that I've given a full talk you
can refer to my video cassette of Quran
modern science and is the Quran God's
word inshallah inshallah if you watch it
with an open mind you have to be
convinced that there's one God and he is
the creator of the
universe thank you can we have the next
question from the mic at the
back or
and other
gratefulness
pra the Brother P a question in Hindi
I'll give the translation English he
said that God loves even he loves God
human beings love God the moment you
love God all these good quality that
mentioned about honesty about charity
come
automatically so is it required that we
should follow the Commandments mentioned
in the Quran is it a requirement
brother if everything comes
automatically you will automatically
follow what is mentioned in the Quran
but everything doesn't come
automatically to everyone you understand
so what Allah wants if you love your
creator for example I say that I love my
mother I love my mother my mother tells
me that my son don't tell lies no I love
you mother but what H in
lying my mother says get for me a glass
of water mother I love you very much but
I don't get the glass of
water I am sick please get some tablets
mother I love you very much if I don't
obey the Commandments of my mother what
is the use of this love it is useless it
is a lip
service therefore Allah says in the
Quran in Surah ankabut 29 verse number
two just by saying you believe
Allah will test you if you say you
love Allah will not leave you Allah will
test you so just by saying you love
Allah or just by saying I believe in
Allah believe in God Allah will surely
test you so this life is a test now when
you go for the test if you don't know
the rules and regulation of the test
there'll be a problem for
example if you sit for an examination
first you try and find out what is the
portion of the examination and then you
study that portion so what Allah said
sir certain things are inborn I agree
with you certain things qualities
honesty charity it comes inborn Allah
has put but many things we don't know
not having alcohol is not inborn certain
things that charity is inborn may come
like if anyone suppose anyone is
tortured you feel hurt certain things
are inborn not to gamble is not inborn
so certain things are inborn certain
things are not so what we have to do we
have to follow the Commandments of Allah
subhana wa tala as Allah says this life
is a test so unless unless you do not
read the Commandment of almighty God how
will you pass the test why do I say read
the Quran because this is the only
book which is the revelation of almighty
God which has remained in pran Purity
according to Sir William Mo who was a
staunch critic of Islam he was forced to
write forced means he was compelled he
had no option that there's no book on
the earth which has remained as pure as
the Quran for the past 12 centuries he
said this 200 years back even a Critic
he had no option he couldn't lie here he
had to say so compared to all the other
scriptures of almighty God Allah subhana
wa ta'ala he sent several Revelations by
name you know four Torah zabur inil and
the Quran Torah is the the Revelation
was given to Moses peace be upon Him
zabur is the the Revelation was given to
David peace be upon Him inil is the the
Revelation given to Jesus peace be upon
him and Quran is the last and final
Revelation which was given to the last
and final messenger Prophet Muhammad
sallallah Al wasallam otherwise Allah
says in the Quran in Sur 13:38 we have
sent a revelation every age there were
many more Revelations sent by the
passage of time they have got corrupted
the only one which has remained in pran
Purity is the Quran that's why I say
that if you want to follow the real
command of Allah subh follow this and if
you being a Hindu if you ask me how do I
prove it you have to come for my talk on
the 18th of January on Sunday for
similarities between Hinduism and
Islam can we have the next question from
from the brother's side as Dr saki gave
the explanation just now is totally
agreable and I accept it cuz I'm not a
Christian and I'm a person who thinks
God is should be there as a cell phone
is here there must be someone created it
otherwise is not existence in this world
similarly I believe in God but I don't
have a religion and as Doctor Sagi said
any other religion of worshiping other
than Muslim is a sin but how will you
convince this little man over here that
this only religion is only Islam and
nothing else but maybe the people other
religion things or maybe you people are
doing the sin cuz you are telling we are
sinning and you know these things keeps
on happening between religion and
religion the brother asked a good
question he gave a Christian name if I
heard it correctly but said he's not a
Christian yes he says he believes in God
if there's a cell phone it has a Creator
so that way he believes in God very good
alhamdulillah congratulations but he
says that how can you prove to me that I
should only follow Islam that's a very
good question brother Islam is Arabic
word you may not know the meaning so
forget Arabic leave it aside what you
should follow is Allah says in the Quran
in Imran chapter number 3 verse number
19l the only religion acceptable in the
sight of Allah subhana wa ta'ala it is
Islam which is peace acquired by
submitting your will to Allah subhana
taala if you believe in God that he's
there you don't believe in religion what
is the definition of
religion deligent means believing in God
so if you believe in God and said don't
believe in religion you're
contradicting by definition of Oxford
dictionary religion means believing in a
supernatural
being or God that deserves obedience so
if you believe there is God you also
have to obey him right or wrong that's a
different thing you may not know which
book is God's book you understand so if
you believe in God do you want to obey
this Creator or not yes or no yeah but
first you have to be convincing right
that's I agree with you I'm not telling
you but you have to obey the Creator now
what the Creator said you have to find
out correct so now the brother agrees
that there's a Creator he believes in
God and he agrees that he should obey
that Creator the same thing God is
telling the only way of life acceptable
is submitting your will to God that's it
now what is submitting that's a
different question correct forget the
word Muslim forget the word Islam Muslim
means one who submits the will to
almighty God if you submit a will to God
in Arabic you call Muslim just by
telling your name is Zak Abdullah Sultan
you don't become Muslim if I say my name
is Zak I don't become a Muslim if
someone say his name is Muhammad doesn't
become Muslim Muslim by definition means
a person who acquires peace one who
submits the will to almighty God now you
want to know that how will you say that
this is the right will of God correct
for that you have to refer to my video
cassette is the Quran God's word which
is pro scientifically that this is the
word of God which you and I believe in
you and I believe in this is the same
word of God for that refer to my video
cassette it is approximately 4 hours I
don't intend giving a lecture and a
question for hour here and tomorrow you
can come for my talk sharah Sharia means
the law of Allah law of Islam barbaric
or perfect if you hear that talk it will
partly convince you for complete answer
refer to my video cassette is the Quran
God's word and inshallah inshallah
you'll be convinced that this is the
only way which is right names don't go
on Arabic names don't look at people
what people who don't follow them don't
judge Islam by what the followers are
doing if you want to judge how good a
car is If a driver does not know how to
drive the car and he bangs up the car
who will you blame the driver or the
car driver so don't judge Islam by
looking at the Muslims judge Islam by
the authentic source of the Quran and if
you judge according to this if you want
to judge the car you go at the catalog
what is the speed of that Mercedes car
what is the safety measures what is the
average etc etc or you judge by putting
a driver behind the seat who's an expert
driver so if you want to observe a human
being to know how Islam is the best
example is the last and final messenger
Prophet Muhammad Salli
wasallam the next question from Brother
here yes I'm person now I'm doing my
mbbs sir you said that it was wrong to
kill animals other than necessity that
is for Target productors Etc so in the
present day a man can live very
comfortable and healthy life by being a
vegetarian
so do you think it's wrong to kill
animal for just for the sake of
satisfying our taste Birds brother Pras
asked a very good question very relevant
question to the topic when I said that
you should not kill any animals they are
creational unless you want for food you
cannot target practice though why do the
Muslims kill animals you can lead a
healthy life according to him being an
mbb student so why only kill the animals
for Taste brother Point number one a
Muslim can be a very good Muslim even by
being a you are vegetarian there's no
verse in the Quran or Hadith which says
you should compulsory F have nonv or
have flesh you can be a very good Muslim
by being a pure vegetarian but Allah
subh says in the Quran in Surah MAA
chapter number five verse number one you
can have all the animals which are
lawful for you all for footed animal
which are lawful for you with the
exception named Allah says in Surah
chapter number 16 verse number five that
almighty God has created Animal for you
so that you can eat the meat Allah says
in Sur chapter number 23 verse number 21
that verely in the cattle is a sign for
you from among the body you get a milk
for you to drink and from it you derive
warmth and of the meat you can eat so
when our creator almighty God gives us
permission to have these meat why should
we not have it now coming to your
argument that in this meat you being an
mbbs student even I'm a medical doctor
I've passed my mbbs
and you being being mbbs student you
might have read I don't know which you
and first also you might have read that
that there are certain amino acids which
are not synthesized in the body which
are known as essential amino acids they
are eight amino acids now these
essential amino acids have to be given
in the external diet if you don't take
an external diet it can cause loss to
your body no vegetable on the face of
the Earth gives you all the eight
essential amino acids no vegetable the
only food which gives you all the eight
essential amino acids
is the meat fish the flesh
Foods flesh food is rich in protein rich
in vitamins rich in iron it is healthy
but yet I do know if you want you can
remain healthy even by abstaining from
nonv food you can by having a proper
diet and checking up and Etc you can I'm
not saying you cannot remain healthy but
when the food is healthy why abstaining
from it the reason people give is that
your hurting animals which will come to
it later now if you analyze the set of
teeth of the herous animals the cow the
goat the Sheep they have flat set of
teeth they only have vegetables they
will never touch flesh
never if you analyze the set of teeth of
the carnivorous animal tiger leopard
lion they have canine set of teeth they
have pointed teeth they only have flesh
they never touch grass if you analyze
the human being's teeth if you go and
look in the mirror if I go and look in
the mirror we find that almighty God has
given us flat teeth as well as pointed
teeth if almighty
God if almighty God wanted us to have
only vegetables why did he give us the
canine teeth now you are a medical
student the canine teeth is for flesh
food so this proves that almighty God
gave us for having nonv food furthermore
the digestive system of the herous
animals cow goat sheep they cannot
digest flesh they can only digest
vegetables the diis system of the
Carnivor animals tiger leopard lion can
only Digest flesh they cannot digest
vegetables but the Dig of the human
being you being a medical student know
we can digest non-v also and veg also
vegetables also flesh food also even
flesh food if almighty God wanted us to
have only vegetables why did he give us
a DI system he can digest both but
natural to have it now coming to your
question that there is a
misconception amongst the Hindus that
the Hindu scripture does not permit them
to have nonv I quoted the Quran if you
read the Hindu scriptures brother if you
read manusi chapter number five Manus
smti chapter number 5 verse number 3031
it says that if you eat the Flesh of the
animals which are meant to be eaten
you're not doing a sin because almighty
God has created some animal to eat and
some to be
eaten man SMI chapter number 5: 31 that
if you sacrifice the animal the
sacrifice of animal you're not doing a
sin chapter number 5 verse number 39 to
40 says that Almighty God has created
certain animals to be sacrificed so if
you kill the animal to be sacrificed
you're not killing man SM chapter number
5 verse number 4142 says that a Brahman
who has knowledge who knowingly sacrific
an animal even the animal goes to heaven
and even the Brahman goes to
heaven furthermore in r book number 10
hymn number
27 verse number two a person says that
I'm going to go for war when I come back
you prepare for me a great bull
furthermore book number 10 himym number
28 verse number four it say that Indra
he said that prepare for me Bulls to
eat buffalo bull TW it and if you read
the Mahabharat anushasan per chapter
number
88 if you read that this is also
mentioned Manus chapter number 3 verse
number 266 and
277 yudish he asked bishma what should
we give in the yagna in the Puja in
sacrifice so that our ancestors will be
satisfied so bishma replies that if you
give herbs and shrubs vegetables our
ancestors will be satisfied for one
month if you give fish they'll be
satisfied for two months if you give
meat they'll be satisfied for 3 months
if you give hair rabbit they'll be
satisfied for 4 months if you give goat
meat they be satisy for 5 months if you
give bacon for 6 months if you give deer
for 7 months if you give birds for eight
months and the menu
continues this is scripture of Hindus it
further says that if you give a buffalo
for 11 months and if you give cow for 12
months and roseris
inexhaustibly so even according to Hindu
scriptures even according to Hindu
Scriptures it gives you permission to
have nonv including beef I'm not saying
this all the references are there you
can check it up it's absolutely correct
now coming to The Logical point of it
that why do the human beings have to
harm the animals
when we can live without eating nonv the
reason people give that killing an
animal is a great sin and killing a
plant is a lesson because plant don't
have life this was the logic previously
Hindu sages and S they had Don they had
beef also but they were influenced by
the Jens of the AA philosophy who
believed that plants have got no life
therefore eating a plant is a lesser sin
as compared to eating an animal but
today you know and even I know that
plants have got life so now the logic
has changed they say okay brother Zakir
we agree plant have got life but plant
can't feel pain therefore killing a
plant is a lesser sin than killing an
animal today science has further
Advanced and you have come to know that
even the plants can feel pain the plants
have a nervous system they can feel pain
they can even cry they can even feel
happy they even feel sad but the Cry of
the plant cannot be heard by the human
beings because the human beings can only
hear between a frequency of 20 cycles
per second to 20,000 cycles per second
anything below and above they can't here
you may be aware of a silent dog whistle
the dog can hear up to 40,000 cycles per
second so the whistle has a frequency
above the human frequency more than
20,000 cycles per second but below
40,000 cycles per second the master
Blows the Whistle human being can't hear
the dog hears and comes so even the
plants cry but we can't hear just
because we can't hear that doesn't mean
that we can torture them if you say it's
torturing there was one person who
arreed with me and told me Zak I agree
with you plants have got life plants can
feel pain but the plants have got only
two or three senses animals have got
five senses therefore killing a plant is
a lesser sin as compared to killing
animal I told him okay brother for sake
of argument agree with you plants have
got two or three senses animal have got
five senses but suppose you have a
brother he's born deaf and dumb two
senses less can't speak can't hear when
he grows up somebody comes and kills him
so will you go and tell the judge oh me
Lord give the murderer L punishment
because my brother are two senses
less you
you will tell him give him a bigger
punishment he was a mum you are sinless
how did he kill my brother so Islamic
logic doesn't work like that two senses
that's how TR s more Allah says in the
Quran in Surah Bak 2 verse number 168
eat of the good things we have provided
you what is good you can have what is
not good you cannot have if you
analyze that if you don't kill these
cattles life cycle of the cattle is very
short they reproduce very fast if you
don't kill the cattles for food you'll
have a problem of overp population of
the cattles
the cow and the Goat they reproduce very
fast and if an Indian does not want to
have nonv I've got no problem if you
don't want to have nonv brother no
problem at all personally I'm happy
because if all the Indians and the
Hindus start having non-v then the price
of meat will go
high can we have the next question from
the sister's side I see there is uh I
cannot offend my Muslim sisters anymore
uh we can give you a chance yes sister
you can ask a question asalam alaykum
the question is not really related to
your topic but one of the sisters here
would like you to elaborate on this we
feel that by sending our children to
secular schools they are losing their
Islamic values however there are many
other sisters who feel it's fine to send
them to secular schools as long as they
are taught Islam at home please comment
sister POS a question I do agree thought
of the topic the chairperson gave her a
chance so I have to
answer she said that is it right if we
send our children to secular schools and
teach Islam at home sister secular by
definition means nothing to do with
God if you send your children to secular
schools secular School nothing to do
with God but I know what you meant what
do you meant for non-islamic schools run
by Christian Mission others secular
school by definition means nothing to do
with God if you sent to a school with
nothing to do with God those are atheist
there will be a problem they will teach
there's no God you will teach at home
there is God there will be conflict the
child will have a problem similarly if
you sent to other schools which teach
wrong things who teach to worship other
besides God so there they worship Jesus
Christ peace be upon him every day in
the morning and you come and say that
worshiping Jesus Christ is sh so the
child will get confused you know what we
are doing it is we who are creating
problem in the children we are to blame
it the duty of the parents to give an
atmosphere which is right atmosphere it
is like you're tying your children tying
the hands and the leg putting the
swimming put say swim how will you
swim so sister my advice is we do
require the worldly knowledge it's
important the first guidance of our
creat Allah subhana wa tala in the Quran
to humankind inah 96 verse number one is
is to
read is to educate our beloved Prophet
said it is obligat on every Muslim man
or woman to acquire knowledge so
knowledge is a must both knowledge
religious as well as the other worldly
knowledge both is important sister but
be careful while running after the other
worldly knowledge religious knowledge
should not go behind both should be
there so best is put your children in
schools which do not
conflict with the Commandment of the
Creator Allah subhana wa
tala but the best is schools which teach
both imagine you go to school and they
are taught about D we have been created
from monkeys and Allah say we have been
created from Adam now the child gets
confused how many confusion will you
remove the best is Islamic schools
unfortunately unfortunately there are
very few Islamic schools but
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah now
throughout the world including India
there are many Islamic schools springing
up some of good quality some medium
quality some lower quality what we
should do that we should support those
people who are opening such schools and
alhamdulillah even our Islam Research
Foundation irf educational trust has
started a school three years back in
Bombay by the name of Islamic
international
school and we are striving so that we
can give to our children what we didn't
get what we lacked in our childhood we
have a school we have started inshallah
besides having the formal education I
don't call it secular mathematics is not
secular science is not secular I call it
formal education because science is the
Islamic subject according to me
mathematics is Islamic subject the great
mathematicians are Muslims the great
scientists are Muslims so I don't call
science as a secular subject I call it
for the non-muslims formal education
islamically it's an Islamic subject but
should be taught in the correct
perspective scientific facts not
hypothesis and theories like darn
theories Etc so sister it is important
that we give our children the right
atmosphere and see to it that they get
the right education that's the best if
you try and say that they go to a school
which teaches wrong things and then come
home and teach the right things about
the creation of Allah subhana wa ta'ala
and the religion sister you are playing
with fire I would advise you put in
Islamic school hope to answer the
question the next question from the
brother's side at the back may peace and
mercy of God be upon you all my name is
sanak
Kumar see Quran says God exist
everywhere and others also saying God
exist everywhere and within everything
and somebody says within ourselves also
God is there and if God exist in
everything means why don't we worship in
ideal there is also a god no then if not
where God exist please explain thank you
the brother asked a very good question
peace be on YouTube
brother peace mercy and blessings of
Allah subhana be on you brother brother
asked a very good question that even the
Quran it is mentioned that God exists
everywhere the Muslims believe God exist
everywhere even the Hindus believe God
exist everywhere so what's the har in
worshiping an idol God exists in the
idol God exists in human beings also so
what's the harm in worshiping an idol
brother nowhere in the Quran is it
mentioned that God exist
everywhere nowhere in the Quran is it
mentioned God exist everywhere I'm aware
there is a misconception amongst many
Muslims who assume God exist everywhere
nowhere does the Quran say they exist
everywhere what the Quran says Allah's
power exist
everywhere Allah has the power the of
the Quran wherever you turn your faith
you'll see the vge of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala the faith mean the power of Allah
subhana wa taala Allah is capable of
controlling anything and
everything but the statement he exist
everywhere is not mentioned anywhere in
the Quran neither in any Hadith I'm
aware that there are certain Muslim lot
of misconception they believe that this
is nowh mentioned but his power exist
power exist everywhere now regarding a
question where does God exist and why
can't we worship an idol where does God
exist the Quran
says Allah is on the AR the Hadith where
a lady approached and the prophet asked
her where is God she said point on Top
God said she has IM she has Faith so God
exists on the arsh on the throne the
throne exists on the water he's up in
the heavens so but natur he's not in the
human being yeah they can control Allah
says he's closer to you than your
jugular wi that means he is aware of
everything his power is there that
doesn't mean God himself has come into
the jagular that doesn't mean that it
means that Allah has power he's close to
you that means he loves you he knows you
he knows everything he has power over
everything not even a leaf can fall
without the permission of Allah subhana
wa tala now coming to your question why
can't we worship idols if you read the
Quran Quran says in Surah ma 5 vers
number 90 which I quoted idol worship is
prohibited same thing if you read the
bhagad Gita bhagad Gita says in chapter
number 7 verse number 20 all those with
intelligence a note down brother bhagad
Gita chapter number 7 verse number 20
all those who intelligence has been
stolen my material desires they worship
Dem
Gods so materialistic people they do
idol worship if you read the CH chapter
number six section number two verse
number one it
says it's a Sanskrit condition which
means god is only one without a second
it's mentioned in
the chapter number six verse number
n of him there are no
Lords he has got no parents almighty God
has got no father he has got no mother
almighty God has got no Superior he has
got no master it's mentioned in
thean chapter number four verse number
19 of him there is no likeness it
further repeated in chapter number 32
verse number
three of him there are no images
almighty God has got no images so the
moment to make an image of almighty God
you're going against the Veda you're
going against bhagat Gita bhagat Gita
Vedas all these scriptures they speak
against idol worship for the detail you
can come to my talk on not tomorrow next
Sunday 18th of January on similarities
between Hinduism and Islam and I'll deal
with this topic in detail so even idol
worship is prohibited in
Hinduism why do they do the Hindu
Scholars have a certain logic which you
can reply to that also you come for my
talk similarities between Hindu and
Islam and inshallah you'll get more
knowledge on this aspect hope that
answer the
question the same question was answered
if you have a counter question on that I
have a doubt on that sir first of all
you misunderstood my question I'm not
here to contradict Islam or nor I'm an
advocate of Hinduism or anything I'm
just my question is just based on your
speech you said it was wrong to kill
animal for pleasure right so I just want
to know that eating out of suppose I'm
thinking mutton is tasty so out of my
own personal pleasure I'm killing animal
is it wrong I'm not trying to contradict
you or put into a doubt just want to
know your point of view that's all
brother you're most welcome to ask any
question I don't feel hurt at all I know
you're not contradicting even if you
contradict no problem brother it's my
job I'm a d it's my profession you can
criticize me you can criticize the Quran
I'm young but I can take it
alhamdulillah no problem brother I don't
get agitated you can ask any questions
no problem brother the question he said
that when I said him at talk that you
cannot kill for pleasure of hunting I
said for pleasure hunting you cannot
kill any animal just without any purpose
pleasure of hunting here we don't eat
nonv only for Taste we eat for our
sustainance so if you say we can't eat
animals we can't eat plants also what
will we eat how will we survive how will
we survive
so gra for you I'm not asking if I'm
eating it for necessity suppose I think
okay this animal food is going to be
tasty I want to kill it for my personal
pleasure alone not I'm feeling of hunger
nothing is it also a sin if it's for
eating for eating tasty food also no
problem you have to eat if you don't eat
you can't survive if you don't eat you
can't survive so almighty God as
mentioned Manus smiti chapter number
five verse number 30 some animals have
been created to eat some to be eaten not
read it no but I have read it not
interested in knowing about that I'm
just asking your point of view is it
wrong my point of view is it wrong to
kill animal on the basis of just merely
taste pleasure it is not wrong at all to
kill an animal even if you want to have
tasty as long as it is for food okay
thank you why because Quran gives
permission in Sur MAA 5 verse number one
manusi gives you don't want to know but
I want to tell people that I believe in
this part of Manti other part I may not
believe but this part of Manus believe
Chapter 5: 30 that almighty God created
some animals to eat some to be eaten so
if you eat the animals which have been
created to be eaten you're not doing a
sin similarly Quran also says certain
animals have been created to be eaten
but if you eat the other animals which
have not been great for eating then it's
a sin so those cattles like sheep Etc
which are permitted in the Quran that if
you eat for food even if it's tasty food
no problem some people want to have
vegetable tasty vegetable some people
like bringol some people like lety
finger so no problem if I agree with you
that nothing should be eaten then you
will have to kill either the plant or
the animal so while eating if you're
eating good things as long as they not
wasting if you waste food it is wrong
if you waste food it is wrong so if you
kill for eating for sustainance even if
it's tasty no problem it's permitted
it's mentioned in the Quran Sur ma 5
vers number one Sur 16 verse number 5 as
well as Sur 23: 21 hope that answer the
question can we have the next brother
okay brother what's the question one
more question sir see the world has
strung only the present age a few
decades back or few centuries back I
don't think so the preaching of Islam
was throughout the world right you said
it was wrong to associate any followers
with God is the greatest sin but a
person brought up in some part of the
world telling that okay this is Lord
Shiva Lord Vishnu or Jesus whatever is
led into believing that okay that is
only God is he also committing a sin a
very good question asked that the world
is so big and Islam just 14 years back
according to him and people may not know
about Islam somebody believes in Shiva
as Lord or Brahma as Lord so what's the
problem someone believe that Jesus
Christ is God what's wrong I being a
student of compared religion besides
Quran saying it is wrong even the Hindu
scripture says and the Christian
scriptures regarding Jesus Is God I
quoted so if the Christian scripture
says it is wrong so why should the
Christian worship tomorrow someone calls
you God someone calls me God what agreed
what we have to what is wrong is wrong
regarding calling Brahma calling Brahma
as God or Shiva as God if you anal these
statements are mentioned in r r book
number two himym number one verse number
three there are no less than 33
attributes given to almighty God in r
book to him one alone one of them is
Brahma Brahma Creator God if you
translate Creator to Arabic it means
khik we Muslims have got no objection if
someone says almighty God is khik or
Creator or Brahma but if someone says
Brahma is almighty God who has got four
hands and on each head is a crown we
Muslims take strong objection to it
moreover you're going against J chapter
number 32 verse number three which
says of that God there are no images
same thing Vishnu Vishnu this sustainer
God if you translate sustainer or
cherisher into Arabic we Muslims have
got no objection in someone God almighty
God as ra sustainer or cherish or Vishnu
but if you say Vishnu is almighty God
who's traveling on a couch of snakes he
has got four hands one hand is a discus
left hand he has a conch he's traveling
on a b guda we take strong objection to
it moreover you're going
against chapter number four verse number
19 which
says of him there are no images so
brother if certain people follow wrong
things if they follow Brahma as the
Creator who has got no image of the
almighty without associating Partners
there's no problem regarding a question
that people may not know Islam Islam
brother as I said in my talk is not a
new religion which came into existence
14 years back it is the S time
immemorial and Jesus Christ peace be
upon him also taught Islam he said not
my will Gospel of John 5:3 not my will
but the will of my father anyone who say
not my will but will of almighty God is
a Muslim so Jesus Christ pleasa be upon
him was a Muslim he taught nothing but
submitting a will to God which you you
translate into Arabic means
Islam Adam peace be upon Him Tau nothing
but submitting a will to almighty God
Noah taught nothing but submitting a
will to almighty God Moses T nothing but
submitting the will to almighty God
Jesus Tau nothing but submitting the
will to almighty God may peace be upon
them all if translate to Arabic is Islam
mhammad sallahu Ali wasallam is the last
and final messenger he was not sent only
for the Muslims or the Arabs Allah says
in the Quran in Surah chapter number 21
verse number
107 that we have sent thee not but as a
mercy to the whole of humanity as a
mercy to the whole of mankind as a mercy
to all the creatures as a mercy to all
the worlds therefore it's the duty of
every Muslim I ended my talk by saying
the quotation of the Quran of Surah Al
Imran chap 3: 110 which says it's the
duty of every Muslim to convey The
Message of Islam to the others and Allah
says in the Quran in Surah f chapter
number 41 verse number 53 Allah
says that soon we shall show them our
signs in the furthest of the horizons
and into their souls until it is clear
to them that this is the truth there may
be some people living in some far off
Island which no one may have heard about
Islam according to you Allah says he
will put the message of the creator in
everyone's Heart by the signs and the
horizons and into the soul so Allah
subhana wa tala the Creator he himself
will give the message of submitting the
will to God
directly so even if we don't do the job
yet he will get the message and then if
you reject it you will be a loser if you
accept it you have passed this test hope
that answer the
question can we have the next question
from the sister's
side if Allah knows that people will do
sins when when they are sent back again
to Earth after removing the thoughts of
Hellfire why did he not show the mankind
that even to people of today's
generation that these are his
punishments so that people seeing them
by their own eyes fear Allah and go in
right
path sister has a very good
question that if you see the real thing
in the next life in the here after see
the Hellfire everyone will believe that
we should have believe we made a mistake
but Allah cannot send them back and wash
their memory because they will again
commit the same sin so why doesn't Allah
show them here that's a very good
question sister Allah does give trials
over here also Allah mentioned in the
Quran about the Hell Fire but
what we think that where is jna where is
we see that afterward so we don't
believe in it Allah has told but we
don't believe in it regarding trials
Allah gives you trailer you know
highlights here for example AIDS Allah
says in the Quran has punished many of
the people many com many nations
previously and he extin completely k l
and various coms even today you know
AIDS AIDS came in the ' 80s early ' 80s
it's a punishment punish from Allah
acquired immune deficient syndrome AIDS
that's a punishment first homosexuals
got it then heterosexuals got it do
outside their marriage so here we find
Allah gives us signs all these are signs
for example Bosnia it's a
Calamity the people
Bas two ways some people did wrong
people are Muslims how are they were
they practicing most of them weren't
practicing Muslims they didn't know
Islam so Allah giv signs there may be
good people also in Bosnia so Allah says
when he gives this punishment even those
who don't do sin may get punished for
them it's a test the Calamity when Allah
sends a Calamity even those people who
are not sinful Allah says in the Quran
even the Calamity May befall them but
that's for them a test so here all all
these are test sister what's happening
in the world today Bosnia what's
happening you seen the other part what's
happening in Iraq all these are test but
where do we human beings
reflect so all these are signs sister
Allah is giving you
trailers and if you read this book the
last and final guidance and we realize
it then we realize he is the creator he
alone should be worshiped and we always
say alhamdulillah whatever he has given
us hope that answer the question
can we have the next question from we
have time for a couple of questions more
the last two questions yes brother
alikum sir this is perhaps my first
meeting uh with Dr Zakir naak and I'm
very convinced by his speech can we have
your name and your profession mza mza is
my name and I'm doing my
MBA so I had a small question sir you
have told me that uh Allah Allah knows
that what each of us are going to do
what each of us are going to do next why
this world has been created and where we
lead to what am I going to do the next
moment also has been
decided okay
so is this word test Justified because
uh the very fact whenever we use the
word test logically speaking it is
perhaps an event where the consequences
are not known so in wherever we use the
word test that this world is a test so
are we justifying because if we already
know if Allah knows what is the
consequences going to be where each of
us are heading to and what each of us
are going to be so why why are we here
and uh I a question brother one question
at a time please no I just want to
complete this things complete the
question yeah yeah and uh if you are the
scientist and if you have an experiment
and you know what is the consequences
going to be so why the experiment and
why do you want to do it the brothers
asked a question inshallah if the
non-muslim should come up first on the
microphone we prefer non-muslim asking
the question volunteers should see to it
that non-muslim should be bought front
if any non-muslims your most welcome you
can walk through you can break the queue
come in front it will be preferable
brother M ask a question that when a
test takes place the consequence is not
known if the consequence known where is
the test if a scientist does experiment
he doesn't know the result if he knows
the result then what's the test very
good no one is testing
Allah Allah knows the consequences but
Allah is not undergoing the test we are
undergoing the test and you and I don't
know the consequence I don't know my
consequence I don't know I'm going to go
to Jenna if I had known I was going to
go to jna I would have come all the way
to Madras I travel throughout the world
I sweat it out I don't know my jna is
not secured if my jna was secured then
why would I left my medical profession
and locked out here and this I don't
know I'm not sure I'm going to go to
Jenna I'm asking for the grace of Allah
subhana wa tala be merciful put me in J
I pray to Allah subhana tala I can out
I'm a great die I go to jna the
consequences is not known to the person
who under go the test you do not know
whether you go to Hell or Heaven I don't
know but Allah knows and you may have
missed out the point in my lecture that
when the teacher takes examination many
a Time the teacher knows the
consequences teacher knows this student
going to come out first teacher know he
going to fail so do you mean to say I
will not sit for the examination the
test is yours the test is not for the
teacher and when the scientist does the
experiment the scientist doesn't know
the result therefore he does the
experiment
yeah Allah subhana tal is not a
scientist Allah is not experimenting on
us there's a mistake Allah is not
experimenting on us Allah subhah wa
ta'ala is the creator the best to create
he's given made a creation the human
beings who has a free will he knows but
the reason is letting us go in this
world because if he does not let you
undergo this test on the day of judgment
you will ask Allah subhana tala why did
you put me in hell if Allah puts you in
help allaham I don't know so you'll
object so because of that I said in my
lecture that Allah subhana tala is just
so Allah is not undergoing the test
Allah doesn't require us Allah is
already the greatest we are undergoing
the test and we don't know the results
because we don't know the results that's
the reason we are striving and we pray
to Allah subhana wa taala may he Grant
his Mercy may he forgive us and may put
us in j a mean and we have the next
question from the brother here I am s
doing btech in
MIT sir you are told that God told I can
can forgive any sin other than accepting
a partner to me to Islams only they are
praying Allah other than that for Indus
that and all we are not following Allah
that and all so we are sinners in your
point of view the question that Allah
says he may forgive anything if he wants
not that he will forgive that doesn't
mean that if you believe in Allah you
can do any sin if he wants he can
forgive you but the sin of shik he'll
never forgive regarding other
non-muslims or worshiping anyone besides
Allah Allah means the true one God you
may call him by any name Allah says in
the Quran in is 17 vers number
110 say call upon Him by Allah or by by
whichever name you call upon him to him
belong the most beautiful names but the
concept should be correct he should not
be begotten he should be one if you
worship the true almighty God whichever
name you call but it should be a good
name correct concept no problem but if
you worship things if you associate
Partners like if someone say Jesus
Christ peace be upon him God we consider
him to be a messenger of God if you call
him God then not only a sinner it is the
biggest sin according the Quran not
according to me according to the Quran
Surah n 4:48 Surah n 4: 116 not only
according to the Quran even according to
the Bible even according to the Bible
almighty God says in the book of
Deuteronomy chapter number 5 verse
number 79 th shall not make image of
almighty God it's a sin even according
to R it's a sin according to
32 vers number three it's a sin so not
only Quran says it's a sin even the
Hindu scriptures says it's a sin suppose
a Muslim says I believe in Allah and he
starts worshiping Muhammad s Ali
wasallam supp a lunatic he says I
believe in Allah but he worships m s Ali
wasallam and says even he will not go to
jenah same way if a Christian worship
Jesus Christ peace be upon him though
the Bible says you should not be
worshiped your vas say you should not be
worshiped so according to your vas you
will be a sinner Accord to bhagat Gita
you'll be a sinner according to the
punishers you'll be a sinner according
to the Quran you'll be a sinner
according to the Bible you'll be a
sinner hope that answer the question
about Creator and creation sir I want to
know your name please m is any
non-muslims in the ladyes side
this okay brother you can continue with
your question human beings mostly
Muslims are
punished T to from Bosnia not to Kashmir
in Iraq Mr Zakir told me that even in
World they are punished sir is there
anything that for one sin in the world
also punished and in the also
punished the question that Muslims are
being punished everywhere in BOS being
punished in other parts of the world we
punished there also and punished in
also if a Muslim is a true Muslim true
Muslim means what the meaning of Muslim
not Zak Sultan Abdullah Muslim means one
who submits the will to almighty God for
a true Muslim these calamities are a
test it's not a punishment and the
maximum calamities came on the prophets
in the they will get J but if you are a
namesake Muslim who say your name is
Abdullah Zak and Muhammad Etc but
namesake Muslim but don't follow
Commandments you can get punished here
and even can get punished there because
Allah says in the Quran inah Al Imran 3:
185 every Soul shall have a taste of
death but the final recompense will be
on the day of
judgment so you may get part punishment
here the balance is
there part punishment this bosia small
part punishment balance is there so
final is there or you may get a Calamity
you may get test
calamities but get J so if you follow
the Commandments you're on the true part
whatever comes you say alhamdulillah
hope the answer the
question okay brother you can ask a
question we have a non-muslim brother
hello I'm VI um I'm a software engineer
and I have certain today's lecture was
very good in Quran as far as I read in
one chapter it says that Allah says to
Jesus that have you told to the people
to worship yourself and your mother as
part of Trinity that means that puts
that Quran believes that Mary and Jesus
are part of Trinity no Christians
believe like that the brother as a good
question the Quran says that Jesus
Christ never told the people that you
worship me and my mother as God no
Christian believes that mother Mary is
god brother your knowledge of
Christianity is limited there are more
than thousands of denominations in
Christianity thousands thousands even I
don't know all and there's the
denomination known as Mar who believe in
the Trinity one of the form of Trinity
is Mother Mary they believe mother Mary
to be God though they are very few now
now they exist or I don't know but if
you read
the books of Christianity it talks about
a sect a denomination which believe that
mother Mary was God hope that answer the
question but I'm basically
Christian so um but according to the
whole Bible I never have found out the
place that where Jesus says that worship
my mother or it is it is like brother
says he's a practicing Christian he
never found in the Bible where Jesus
said that worship Mary peace be upon him
neither did Jesus say worship Jesus
peace be upon him but yet you
worship the Quran doesn't say what Bible
says what Quran says say to the people
some people worship same way Bible says
that never did the bible say that Jesus
Christ peace be upon him said
unequivocal statement in the complete
Bible where Jesus Christ PE himself said
that worship me I am God but yet the
Christians worship you don't worship
alhamdulillah I congratulate you if you
don't worship Jesus Christ as God
alhamdulillah then you're coming closer
to Islam and Jesus Christ PE be upon him
said in the Gospel of John chapter
number 16 verse number 11 to2 I have got
many things to say unto you but he
cannot bear them now for he and the
spirit of truth shall come he shall
guide you onto all truth he shall not
speak of himself all that here shall he
speak he shall glorify me talking about
another Messenger to come talking about
the last and final messenger Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu Ali wasallam so you
believe in the Bible you also have to
believe in the last messenger mentioned
in the Bible that is Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon Him hope to answerers the
question the next question from your
brother good evening sir my question is
why should God create us why should he
keep the test why should he send us to
Hell or Heaven brother the question why
should God create her why should we send
here the whole talk was on that why
said that's what I told the whole talk
was based on that that why should God
create us to test us Etc now someone
appears for an examination mbbs
examination ask yes that's brother the
whole talk was based on that and if you
why should he T us why should he create
us what is the need for him okay fine
why should he create other human beings
okay that's a very good question that
why should he create us as human being
I'll give a different angle to it
because if you analyze Allah says in the
Quran that when Allah asked that who
would like to be sent as a human being
the mountains and all they said no but
the human beings were fools who said no
we want to become human beings because
the other creation they don't have a
free will of their own like Angel no
free will okay they are good but if you
become a human being you have a free
will if you have a free will and then if
you obey Allah then you become higher
than the Angels if you have a free will
and don't obey then you become then you
fail so we human beings are fool
including me myself we said ah we want
to get distinction I among so Quran say
we human the fool who said we want to
undergo the test and now we are tested
you won't come to know now on the day of
judgment Allah will give you that memory
so Allah says in the Quran and Allah
testified in Surah chapter number 7
verse number 172 he brought the children
of Adam from The loins and Allah says
and testified do you agree there's one
God he said yes we agree now the memory
has washed out on the day of judgment
again it will come back to you so we
were the fools who said we want to
undergo the test now somebody wants to
sit for an mbbs examination the teacher
said sit if you have got admission in
the medical college no problem now you
sit if he fail that's his problem if he
pass that's his problem you understand
and the test is different what question
has to be given that is the choice of
the teacher you can't tell oh teacher
why have you given me this question that
is the prerogative of the teacher
whether he wants to give you question
number one question number two whether
he wants to give you a question from
chapter number three or chapter number
five therefore Allah subhana tala G
different questions to different people
in this test some people he makes rich
some people he makes poor some people
healthy some people are disease
different people he test different way
but depending upon the way he test them
the correction is like that if the test
is difficult the teacher corrects the
paper lant if the paper is easy the
teacher pracher corrects the paper very
strictly same way Allah subhana wa tala
depending upon the facility he give the
different human being he tells them
accordingly and he is the most just hope
that answer the
question we'll take one do you have a
question brother all right we'll take
one last question from you and we'll
conclude the program then this regarding
the lecture uh you told in one place
that Angels do not have free will but
somewhere in Quran I read in albahra I
read
that was not willing to bow down to Adam
when Allah told so that is his free will
he took it like that mashah our brother
VI is very learned he read the Quran
[Applause]
masallah VI has read the Quran and I do
agree with him Sur Bak he's quing the
verse of the Quran from Surah Bak
chapter number 2 verse number 34 he says
we told to the angels bow down all bound
on except this is mentioned not only in
Surah Bak it is mentioned minimum of
seven times in the Quran in Surah
chapter number 7 Surah hij chapter
number 15 Surah chapter number 18 same
thing we told to the angels bow down all
bow down except so now El
objected so from this we come to know
that El if you read the translation we
understand for the angel we think but if
you read in Surah chapter number 18
verse number 15 it says that we asked to
the angels bow down all bow down except
El was amongst the
gin you understand so was a gin so now
you tell me brother Zak seven places
Allah said to the angels bow down all
bow down except means angel now one
place in the Quran says he was a Jin so
there's a contradiction correct it's a
contradiction because this is the
translation in Arabic language there is
a law called as law of t t means if the
majority is addressed the minority need
not be addressed for example if there
are 99 doctors and one engineer and if I
say all doctors stand up even that
engineer will stand up because in the
law of T in Arabic grammar the majority
address minority I need not say all
doctors and one engineer stand up but in
English language if I say all doctors
stand up only doctors will stand up that
one engineer will not stand so nowhere
does the Quran say that El was an angel
nowhere we because of the translation
and lack of Arabic knowledge we think we
assume many of the Muslims also assume
but the Quran clarifies in Surah 18
verse number 50 that was a Jin and like
the human beings have a free will so
amongst the Angels there was one Jin
also present who was who was very Pious
but his arrogance that why should I bow
down to Adam he's made from mud I'm made
from fire arrogance that made him
disobey almighty God he was a Jin even
human beings and Jin both have a free
will they can disobey God so here they
disobey God and that's the reason he was
taken out and he is the biggest Satan
and now he tries to attract the people
who are in the path of God and try
distract them from the remembrance of
Allah subhana hope that answer the
question we have
to I know but we have to
close okay go ahead fast I am Mohammad
kajam
Modi retired officer Madras University
as am alikum Dr Zak
sah sir you have told that you have open
Islamic International School in
bombai I request you why not you open
isamic school in Chennai and other parts
of the prises because this is the need
of the day today sir thank you
sir brother you give me the land and
give me the funds inshah I'll open it
[Applause]
thank you very much brothers and
[Music]
sisters la